hey
it's saturday night man in hollywood so
guess what
it's time for for this welcome to fat
man beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernardin hey
um we got some [ __ ] to talk about uh
welcome
to the first ever fat man beyond
of 2021. mark how was your new year
uh it was it was sedate you know i was
not one of those people uh
crashing party houses in the hollywood
hills
filled with hundreds of revelers you say
that you're
like you're implying i did i i imply
nothing i'm just saying you live up in
the hills and you know some folks and so
why it was so quiet here like at
midnight you know or five minutes or
maybe two minutes midnight we went
upstairs onto the top deck and for those
that don't
follow uh i live up in the hollywood
hills so if you know where the grow
man's chinese theater is or ccl chinese
theater route
um i you know you could walk to my house
from there it'd take you a couple
minutes and you're going up a hill but
but i'm real [ __ ] close so even
though we live that proximity
to hollywood boulevard we never hear
hollywood boulevard even when
life was bustling and people were out
and [ __ ] we're kind of nestled up in the
hills
so it kind of cuts off the sound so it
was quiet we went out on the deck
dead [ __ ] quiet in our neighborhood
and then i heard something
and i looked up and mary lou henner from
taxi
lives above me you know the lady with
the [ __ ] killer memory like she knows
she remembers everything she remembers a
time when we weren't [ __ ] breathing
through masks mark i could barely
remember that anymore
so her and her family were on their
[ __ ] deck like doing the same thing
and [ __ ]
and so like you know people were
starting to
and then you start hearing other
neighbors but like
from their backyards and [ __ ] like that
and then
like people start counting down ten
seconds the whole [ __ ] neighborhood
and the neighborhood's not like houses
next to each other they're [ __ ]
spread out and [ __ ]
but everyone's yelling through the
canyon like nine hey
seven we counted down and everyone was
screaming you know happy new year
and i was like [ __ ] you 20 20. this is
really
kind of it was somber and quiet um but
no parties but
it was there was this weird little
community moment i felt like [ __ ] i
was in network i was like i'm mad as
hell
and i'm not gonna take 2020 anymore kirk
182
wow what was it it was like someone new
sullivan blue for turquoise tyler 2
and sullivan blue or something
um what did you guys do you just home
with the family did you watch anything
um we actually we went to um
the stranger things drive-in experience
um which is you know that seems to be
the only
live theater that's happening anymore in
any real way is
come to this place stay in your car and
drive through and we'll show you some
[ __ ] through your car windows
and i've been to a handful of them like
there was one for christmas like it's
the
it's whatever the holiday lights and
then there was the halloween one and you
just
you're just driving through like look
there's jack-o'-lanterns and
look there's more jack-o-lanterns and
look that jack-o'-lantern is part of
like famous people
but this was uh sponsored and done in
participation with netflix
um and it's this big [ __ ] thing where
you go downtown oh yeah they spend money
on this
a lot of people this is this is and i'm
spending lots of money
it's i mean it's just like like the
first thing i hear is like
stranger things drive through who's
[ __ ] paying for that then when you're
like netflix i'm like of course
of course they're paying for it um but
yeah you go down you go
downtown it's in like the arts district
of downtown l.a
and you know there's a holding pen for a
thousand cars it's like the star court
mall parking lot and they got like a
little show up on the screen
but there's a chemical leak and then you
go into this parking garage
and basically you're spiraling up into
this
thing and you're going through like the
rift and you're seeing the demogorgon
and doing a suit
and you're seeing the kids from scoops
ahoy and they're running between cars
and then you're moving through the
upside down and then it's super
well done like the light show and
there's snow in the atmosphere
and like giant screens kind of telling
you this weird
abridged version of the story until you
get to the roof of the parking garage
and they've got one of those
giant um projection screens that they
put up it's like
literally the width of the entire
parking lot and they do the big final
battle between
the mined player and the guy with the
hair
um michael i think his name was and uh
and then
11. and so you've got to get up on the
wires with their head
shave balled and as you know spoilers
[ __ ] i ain't the show now i've
now
way up to date i feel like i don't have
to watch
anyway it was like an hour long
experience you know when you stayed in
your car
the kids loved it because there's a
little bit of like a haunted house vibe
too like people would come to the
to the to the side of the the car when
they were like on a window
um but that was cool and then went home
and like played board games and
watched dick clark's new year's rockin
eve was it
free the netflix thing no
it was expensive the netflix thing for
the consumer
and still sold out through like i bought
tickets in
november for new year's eve and i think
now if you want to take it's
it's middle of january maybe late
january
wow man and they're charging good for
them and [ __ ]
most people give away [ __ ] like [ __ ]
come walk through this and it's
promotional
how often that they're like [ __ ] that
we're going to make money off this [ __ ]
tell you they're going to pay all these
not child actors to pretend to be
teenagers
sure it's true that that's gotta be real
finn wolf hard
yes thank you um from one pun
uh lousy pun to a good pun it's a happy
day kids a happy birth
day today um here on fat man beyond
we don't get to do the show unless we do
it
well generally at this coming villainy
cantina
um where it's owned by our good friend
jc and jc is his birthday today jc come
on with us man
hello happy birthday
thanks how old are you uh i am 40 years
old today
4-0 it's a big one [ __ ] 40 year old
non-virgin we know that because you got
a baby
[ __ ] a man well what we've set up
kids for this entire episode
is since we all get this show for
free and whatnot um y'all were so good
about when we
did a benefit or when we've done
benefits plural and whatnot
so this show is gonna benefit that guy
right below us man it's jc's birthday
show
there's a link uh what is it in the chat
jc
it's in uh it's in the description i can
paste it in the chat as well
uh it's streamlabs.com
scum and villainy cantina um if you
love this show and you love that man
who makes the show possible down below
mr j.c
ruthenberg is it reefenberger reifenberg
uh reifenberg
is it really it's not too [ __ ] german
i'm married to a schwab so
[Laughter]
if you want to help out jc reifenberg
ladies and gentlemen uh there is
a link you go to man show him some
[ __ ] birthday love
man he's made these home shows possible
and whatnot
uh plus he's got a goddamn new kid for
heaven's sakes
and he's supposed to have like the best
birthday vacation ever right you were
going to tour star wars filming
locations
oh that's right yeah yeah so i was
supposed to i think i said this last
week or two weeks ago
my 40th birthday plan when i turned 39
i said to jen my fiance
uh not jen your wife that uh i
was who's also schwab who's
also jen smith which is really confusing
i said for for my 40th birthday
i want to go and start in northern
california and visit
every filming location for the first six
star wars movies
and so that was the plan cool man that's
really cool
so what would that like just off top of
your head what are those places so are
you talking about like tunisia
so yeah so i was gonna start up in
northern california and go to endor
and then hit death valley go down to
guatemala which was yavin 4
then shoot across to england to see the
sound stages
that they shot on and then go over to
norway which is hoth
they go down to italy which is naboo
and then end in tunisia which was
tatooine
so it's going to take like three or four
weeks and just take pictures of me with
my action figures in all the different
spots
yeah that's cool and then kovid
and then i had a baby so now i was like
well maybe i can do it for 50
when she's 10 maybe
a family trip well i think
the family trip will be jen and the baby
will go stay in
italy for a month well i go to all the
places they have no interest
in i don't know 10 year old a 10 year
old daughter of yours that's built
from some of your semen i'm sure is
going to be interested in [ __ ]
parkour's locations man plus you'll have
the bars
family [ __ ] business forever sex or
she will not care at all
that's what i'm concerned about is that
she's just gonna be like
she's gonna spend enough time out in my
studio
which looks like your office only with
star wars crap
that she doesn't want anything to do
with star wars
yeah no no you don't know but again my
kid don't give a [ __ ] about star wars
not either but you're seeing the movie
like the movies but she's not like oh my
god they're my religion
or anything like that nor does she give
a [ __ ] about the peanuts which like
blows my mind i'm like
kind of [ __ ] red-blooded american kid
don't like snoopy and
there's an entire generation of
red-blooded american kids
[ __ ] spooky go figure man um
it's so weird it must be like when my
parents
started like noticing pop culture change
where i'm like let's go see star wars
and like star wars what about bonanza
and [ __ ] like that
that's where i am right now old man
style um all right so it's jc's [ __ ]
birthday show ladies and gentlemen
so while we uh talk about uh cobra kai
a little bit and talk about the news and
do some q and a's and stuff
um start pumping out start opening up
your hearts
and your wallets and let's shower jc
with some uh birthday gold a golden
shower for
for jc on his birthday make it rain
yes
um speaking of the best possible way you
have not
dove into uh kobrakai mark have you
i have not i saw that i saw the very
first episode
um of the very first season and like dug
it but
for some reason never went any further
not because just as mentioned before i'm
still you know [ __ ] stolen caught up
with stranger things so sometimes
a thing just slips by uh when kobe kai
started on youtube
red i guess it was their premium or
whatever um
i didn't catch it until right before
season two
launched they put up another billboard
and it said you know season one
you know all available season two this
day so i joined up for
youtube red so i could watch it and i
binge the [ __ ] out of that show man i
loved [ __ ] season one and season
season two of cobra cut
i was like incredibly heartbroken and
crestfallen
uh by the season finale which was empire
strikes back [ __ ] tragic and [ __ ]
where you were like wait
what that's how you're gonna leave it um
and i couldn't wait for season three
and then of course as we learned netflix
picked up
the show youtube read i don't think they
exist anymore
so all the episodes went to netflix and
over the summer the show became we're
over the quarantine i guess over the
summer
the show became [ __ ] huge and
rightfully so
this is honestly like one of the most
entertaining
one of the most heartfelt [ __ ] shows
um
it is truly a soap opera in the best
possible way
i am incredibly wrapped up with these
characters
um i i had no idea how much i
enjoy the miyagi verse for lack of a
better
description because it's constantly
weaving in
faces you know that we saw in only a
couple movies but then you saw him in
karate kid crowded kid two
three maybe [ __ ] four and that was it
so they're
really great the storytellers the
creators and whatnot
um their names escaped me but i was
really happy to see that they
two of them directed the first two
episodes of the season which i was
always like
that's what show runners should do man
if you write this [ __ ] you should
definitely direct it because it's not
like direct and takes
you know brilliance and [ __ ] like that
you if i [ __ ] direct
anyone could direct and so i was happy
to see that two of them
directed co-directed the first two
episodes of this current season
um i have watched the first two episodes
of midway through the third episode of
season three
show has not [ __ ] disappointed i've
already cried four [ __ ] times
uh it's insanely well done the plotting
that they do
like you know part of me would love to
be in the writers room as they [ __ ]
like
must congratulate the [ __ ] out of
themselves going oh that's going to be
amazing because it is each and every
[ __ ] time
everyone's motivations are perfectly
clear
um and makes sense uh you know they've
got they brought back uh martin cove
crease
you know who is the the cobra kai
[ __ ] instructor he came in i think if
i remember season two
so by the end of the season too he's
just like chaos incarnate and he [ __ ]
takes over the dojo and [ __ ]
and in the second episode of season
three
they do a really nice piece of [ __ ]
storytelling spoilers if you haven't
watched
uh see episodes one or two of season
three of cobra kai
skip this i'm not gonna it's not like i
can't spoil that much but
um there's this wonderful opening
to the scene because the whole show is
clearly
like you know about mentors and students
like everyone's a miyagi in the show
daniel russo is a maria amiyagi
uh johnny is a miyagi and even kris
is a [ __ ] miyagi and it's like three
different
senses and senseis and how
each of their their pupils
go out into the world more or less and
and for me like
the fact that i'm i'm deeply into the
adult characters because i recognize
them from the movies i grew up watching
where i'm like oh they fought creases
back
but they do an excellent job these
storytellers uh
somebody jc pull up their names i don't
want to keep calling them the
storytellers there's three of them so
the first stoner that's i know one of
them's hurwitz because i'm always like
mitchell hurwitz and it's not mitchell
hurwitz but it's another hurwitz man
and um apparently that name is tv gold
you're a hurwitz you're a [ __ ] great
writer as far as i'm [ __ ] concerned
um they they do this opening
of episode two with this flashback to
like a tough guy in the 60s and [ __ ]
he's a real prick
and clearly it's crease like they're
like
they're gonna tell you a little bit of
creases backstory
and then this guy bullies this [ __ ]
like you know nice bus boy and [ __ ] like
that
and then a service man comes in and he's
just like
you know vietnam needs people like you
son and he gives
the the jock crease looking guy
this [ __ ] you know pamphlet and the
so the guy walks away the army guy walks
away
and the bully jack guy tosses it
crumples it throws it on the ground like
[ __ ] this
and the busboy picks it up and you're
like no
what a wonderful bait and switch that
ain't [ __ ] crease
this is crease and you they gave crease
a [ __ ]
origin where they humanized them man
where
they didn't make them a good guy but
like you know they're not like you know
he's just a mush mustache twirling
[ __ ]
movie villain prick they gave him a back
story where
you know it doesn't necessarily excuse
him being what he is but it tells you
why he is the way he is man i i'm
telling you like
it's i'm sure someone out there will
like crap on me and be like come on this
is remedial storytelling
but it's incredible remedial
storytelling like
i don't think it's remedial i don't
think anybody can [ __ ] look at this
show
and see anything but an intricately
plotted wonderful love letter
to childhood but also to adulthood man
like
it reminds me of degrassi the next
generation where it's like
they're able to take the characters you
love them bringing a bunch of new
characters that
at your age you shouldn't give a [ __ ]
about but i love the kids like the
karate kids in in the show there's a
whole generation of kids and last season
ended
with a big [ __ ] fight in school and
the opening of this episode they
acknowledged it like they had the news
where they were like
something what we could only describe as
a karate
riot happened in the school and [ __ ] um
there's uh it's you know it's well-acted
um well-written uh well-directed
and every [ __ ] episode that you
usually get
some [ __ ] karate and you forget like
because it's so well made and you're
enjoying the soap opera
theatrics and and the characters and and
their relationships to one another
you're really rooting for all these
[ __ ]
but at the same time every once in a
while they're like plow and you're like
oh [ __ ]
like i forget how thrilling it is to
watch [ __ ] hit each other and [ __ ]
even if it's you know they're blocking
and whatnot
so it's [ __ ] beautiful it's truly a
love letter
um to what i don't know not even i was
gonna say to the genre i don't know what
john
is but it's quality whatever it is hands
down
it's one of those things that you watch
and you're like
i should quit like well i'm not gonna
ever make something as [ __ ]
wonderful as this uh i i can't wait to
get back to it i've only watched the two
episodes i did not binge
for uh only this reason
i got deeply into writing uh
for the last like week um so i went into
uh clerks three and you know it just i
got to this point where i was like
reading the news and i'm like [ __ ] this
world
so i went to a fake one and uh and it
was so much better there
and uh man oh man i've been having like
a [ __ ]
blast you know how when you're writing
something and you're like you don't want
to sleep like i've been only sleeping
like five hours generally when i sleep
anyway
but i've been getting right the [ __ ] up
because i'm like i want to go back
like i want to dive in like wait what
what are they going to say next like
what's going to be the next scene
so i've been on a like [ __ ] role man
and i timed it
with like i started a fast because after
christmas
well during christmas that whole [ __ ]
christmas week
and after christmas um before everything
before
kind of new year's well i guess like two
days after christmas
i just [ __ ] i was eating myself to like
death during christmas just a lot of
comfort eating
i was eating multiple bagels with like
plural and [ __ ] like that
so i you know i started a fast so i was
i'm writing while i'm fasting and
there's part of me that's like maybe i
should [ __ ]
see if i could take it all the way to
the end see if i could take it
like to like finish the script before
i eat now before you know trigger
warning some people get real [ __ ]
like hey man what the [ __ ]
um i like to fast um and i'm an
intermittent faster meaning i eat on a
20
4 schedule and stuff but then sometimes
like i'll
after i've like gone crazy as i did over
christmas i like to dive into a deep
fast where i
take days where i don't eat my body
still has
fat that it it can consume and [ __ ] like
that
and i've uh you know read up on fasts
and whatnot
talk to professionals um so i don't go
into it
uh ignorant by stretching the
imagination and it's worked for me
completely i don't suggest it
necessarily for anybody else talk to
your doctor
talk to health professionals if you're
remotely interested in that sort of
thing
um i got to say all this [ __ ] because
some people get triggered because to
them i guess it reads like
um uh eating disorder right because
what's
to some people you're not eating for
days at a stretch
isn't that like what anorexia is or
something like that
but i [ __ ] love to eat and i just
take a window where i don't and then
you know when that window's uh [ __ ]
open again believe me i go back
to eating so i i you know there's a lot
of disclaimers because i put up the
[ __ ] text like on
an instagram a couple months ago and
like i got
slammed by a bunch of people who were
like this is insensitive man
like a lot of people you know i forgot
like some people
go through eating disorders and so if
you're triggered by that [ __ ] off for a
minute or two because i just want to
finish talking about that
because it's part of my program and
whatnot and it works for me
um i am on our
115 hours right now
of not eating not hungry at all just
hiked runyon canyon
uh hiked it yesterday for the first time
in like three [ __ ] weeks and then
hiked it again right before we came in
and did the show
feel great and stuff like that so i know
i'm gonna make it like i want to hit
jc's mark jc jump on real quick
last big fast i did i want 138 hours
what's your record
jc uh it was six days so let me look it
up
what the you got to 140 if i remember
correctly
yeah i think i was just beyond you
because you were texting me about it and
i was like
at 1 38 yeah jc was like i'm 140. i was
like god damn it so
this time around i'm gonna hit 140 at
least but there's a part of me
that's like maybe i should just keep
going until i'm done with the script man
because i have been
it's been a nice preoccupation like
writing the script don't
you know prior to this um when i watch
tv that's when i tend to like
eat and particularly overeat and stuff
so
writing i don't eat like and i and i
broke myself of reward behavior so it's
not like
i wrote a good five pages i'm gonna
[ __ ] eat a sub or something like that
so i don't know i probably will stop
tomorrow when i hit 140 which would be
like a record for me
for anyone who's like what the [ __ ] i've
slowly built up to that i started with
like a
24 hour fast and got to 72 hour fast
and have slowly built up to it and stuff
uh but again
if you're interested in that sort of
thing talk to your doctor
or read up on it before you give it a
shot a lot of great videos on youtube
about it by healthcare professionals
jc can vouch she's a and you know jc is
a skinny mini i still to this day
i always go like why the [ __ ] did you do
it but it's not about
losing weight yeah also about yeah it
was just about
a lot of people call like do the
cleanses or the juice cleanse or
whatever it's just kind of like that
and it's always something where like if
i started feeling sick or i didn't
felt if i felt lightheaded you know i i
would immediately stop
right same thing here like if i was like
oh my god i'm dizzy and [ __ ] believe me
i'd [ __ ] be all over some hummus in a
heartbeat
but and again i'm not this is not me
trying to make it seem
tempting people this is just my story
doesn't go for everybody but
after day one i really don't think about
it the only times i think about eating
are when i get bored because again my
body's consuming itself and it's not
consuming [ __ ] muscle
i still have a lot of [ __ ] fat i
don't have a lot of muscle there's no
muscle to [ __ ] consume
so my body goes right for all the stored
fat um so
i as i as if my body eats itself and
whatnot i'm not
hungry because it's being fed um and so
like i can go it's particularly if i'm
preoccupied but
if i break and start watching [ __ ]
that's where you know suddenly i'm like
you know what would make this better
look [ __ ] popular or food or anything
and then i graze
like for hours at a time as i watch the
thing that's the behavior
that i want to break in 2021 but one of
my
but like one of my favorite things in
the world is to eat and watch tv
it would be a real hard habits break but
you know
i [ __ ] my time to play is over
so in any event i was writing clerks
three
and i you know they dropped uh
uh karate kid cobra kai
yesterday and if i wasn't involved in my
own storytelling and deeply in love with
what i was doing
i would have been [ __ ] all over that
[ __ ] but today since i knew we were
doing the show
i got to page 62. on my script
and stuff so i'm like over halfway and
so i was like you know what i will put
this down and
you know i feel like it'd be ridiculous
for us to do the show without at least
one of us touching on cobra kai which
has become such a [ __ ] sensation
so i was able to get in two and a half
episodes and the bar
is still incredibly [ __ ] high i'm so
delighted that ralph macchio said yes
because remember as we know and read
like for a long time he was like i don't
want to do this and stuff and i feel so
happy for
like everybody like martin cove and uh
billy zobka like all these cats who
were like oh that was then it's like you
know that happened years ago
nobody's [ __ ] saw this coming and
it's legit
wonderful not only is it like hey come
on back for one more [ __ ] bite at the
apple
they created a whole new orchard like
it's beautiful it's beautiful [ __ ]
storytelling
you would love this you would absolutely
[ __ ] love it like i never push [ __ ]
on you but i'm telling you
and this is something you can watch with
your kids like oh
it's it's multi-generational this is
good [ __ ] man so give it your time
i watched something that you suggested
watch fed lasso this week yes
[ __ ] fantastic hey
i'm telling you man this ain't me
complaining but apple plus has to do a
lot better at [ __ ] selling their
shows
because i i've looked at that for months
and been like and i love
jason sudeikis but i'm like [ __ ]
football i don't care
it and it's like you said it's like has
much to do with footballs as
you know queen's gambit has to do with
chess is character study and
what a fantastic character study like
it's legit wonderful
laugh out laugh out loud funny but
adorable not like you know dirty and
[ __ ] like i do like there's this one
line where he's talking to him he's
trying to get the team to like
bond and he he goes um he goes pillow
fight or movie night
and they're like movie night and he's
like all right but you choose pillow
fight
for one one time we'll never have movie
night again like it was so
[ __ ] legit funny and a really
wonderful warm
like tail like easily digestible
25-minute episodes
he got through that whole season in
under four hours and
it was a gift like i don't know who said
like it's kind of like parks and rec
but it does have that kind of warmth man
it was absolutely wonderful so thank you
for that suggestion
mine back to you is watch watch cobra
guy
i think i will i think i will because we
we just finished um
this has been a shit's creek all six
seasons of shit's creek
um which was lovely and wonderful and
and
yeah similar to ted lasso in that
um it's it's unironic
to a thing that is usually done with
irony
you know that that sense of are these
people just good
are they just learning their lesson you
know like ted lasso was about
you know this guy who is kind of
unrepentantly optimistic
um and it's easy to make that guy the
butt of jokes
but the show does the hard work of like
oh no no he's got there's dimensions to
this person
but and and there are people absolutely
don't understand them but if you spend
the day with ted lasso
you kind of get it but if you spend like
two or three episodes with ted lasso
like you understand
that you know it is he's not you're not
necessarily running from anything
although there's a storyline which
explains exactly why he's in london why
he's
there yeah while he's there but it's so
emotionally mature
about the the the desire to separate
from things that
you might love the desire to learn a new
thing
when you're later in life you know ways
to approach relationships with
with a sense of curiosity like there's
that that great
that's a great speech towards the end of
the first season which is all about like
people are nursing
my whole life and i realized they just
weren't curious because if you're
curious
then you take the time to know somebody
and understand that is a
great great that's a great speech a
really great
you know in the beginning as he started
doing it i was like oh this is kind of
cornball
and then once he got to the meat of it
the heart of it
i was like oh my god this is phenomenal
writing who's
behind this [ __ ] show um bill
lawrence
um who was a guy who did scrubs because
i saw that zach
uh raph directed an episode
yeah bill lawrence and sudeikis like
this this was born
out of a [ __ ] nbc sports ad campaign
um like four years ago for the olympics
like there's a couple of ads
there's just ted lasso um and and
apparently sudeikis was unwilling to
give it up
and just kept on hammering it and
hammering at it and got the lawrence on
board and then they were like yeah let's
make a [ __ ] show
but it's so good headroom
origin story oh like it was an ad that
then became a show and the show
kind of became pretty great it's it is
uh
i i can't it was such a great suggestion
you and somebody else was saying to
watch it too i can't remember was it jc
or i forget but somebody else was like
saying give that a [ __ ] watch and
what a great time i had with it like me
and my wife
rarely watch stuff together as much as
we
should she's usually watching a lot of
[ __ ] like
dateline this [ __ ] killed
another [ __ ] i can't stand
it like that she watches a lot of
snapped and which always spooks me out
because i'm like
[ __ ] each one of the shows is like this
is how she got away with killing her
husband and i'm like
so yeah she's taking notes
so um you know there's uh
like she's not gonna watch cobra kai
with me like you know
my the show that i cannot [ __ ] wait
and i like
[ __ ] my script i'd step on anyone's neck
to see
is wanda vision she's probably not gonna
watch wanda vision with me either and
stuff
mandalorian she you know i showed her
highlights marine delorean and she
really dug
but she didn't like sit through the show
or anything ted lasso
she did um and absolutely loved uh
moon base eight which is on showtime and
with
fred armisen another one that we both
watched together and absolutely [ __ ]
love
but yeah recommend a high recommendation
for everybody i know it's out of genre
ted lasso but it's it's so [ __ ] good
cobra kai in genre watch it as soon as
possible man because
unlike the first two scenes of cobra kai
like where it was happening in a vacuum
more or less unless you had youtube red
now it's happening on the world stage of
netflix it's [ __ ] worldwide and
everyone has found out how [ __ ]
lovely the goddamn thing is so
it's going to be a constant topic of
conversation for the next month
you might as well dive in because it's
not homework
it is so [ __ ] beautifully done it's
one of those
magical things where i'm telling my the
closest thing i could point to is
degrassi for me
where it it is just the right amount of
earnestness
because the show can be incredibly corny
in the best possible
way um but the storytelling and how much
these storytellers
care about the characters and the source
material
um it might i take my hat off to the men
like i
it's it it's a model show for anybody
that's like
let's take an old thing and make it a
[ __ ] new thing but it's a model show
even if you didn't have a [ __ ] old
thing it really helps that they had an
old thing because you're already
emotionally invested but that got me
there through the door
that hasn't kept me around for three
seasons was kept me around for three
seasons
is expert storytelling as far as i'm
concerned and you know some people be
like come on expert and i'm like
a [ __ ] 50 year old man and i make my
own [ __ ] movies and i can go out and
entertain and [ __ ] like that it takes a
lot
to get me off my [ __ ] horse and be
like all right i'm going to sit down and
watch something
and these cats do it effortlessly man
this is like something that i'm willing
to put aside
creating my own [ __ ] you know getting
ahead in my own career
willing to put that aside for this and
you don't say that about
a lot of things man so it's definitely
worth looking out for
i was i was going to wait until uh
hilary swank and jaden smith showed up
um but i i think i will instead
jaded smith i mean i heard the hillary
swank thing i hadn't heard the jaden
smith
and now i guess that's completely
possible too
i didn't really well but i'm karate kids
i still
live into the multiverse and [ __ ]
into the miyagi verse what if you guys
uh
make a bet or a pack that
mark will watch cobra kai as you watch
the fast and the furious movies
i know but it shouldn't mine is
punishment
marx's that's the gift that i'm giving
him man watch cobra care
holy [ __ ] um i'm not i ain't [ __ ]
watching
anything while i'm writing my [ __ ]
movie like because honestly
i'm in love with my movie right now and
in a way that i have been in love with
like a lot of [ __ ] in a long time and i
love what i do but i'm i'm
like it's crazy like i you know it just
makes sense i've been doing it now for
like over a quarter of a century so it
better [ __ ] come natural
but as i'm writing i'm sitting there
going like oh my god like this [ __ ]
what a great way to end the scene and
i'm like
well duh this is like [ __ ] even do it
you better be able to end a [ __ ]
scene properly
after all this time and catching up with
everybody and seeing where they are and
i've talked about what the story of
clerks 3 is it's literally about
them making clerks so essentially
it's it's for me it's like a real
[ __ ] fun trip
down memory lane but with my characters
taking
our parts instead so i it's
that's something that like once i'm done
with that then i'll relax and start
watching other things
but i may continue to dip into
karate kid the danger cobra cut the
danger is
that you know i'll be like well i'm just
getting one more i'm just getting one
more i'm just getting one more and then
you know i've lost today and [ __ ] i'm on
a roll with my [ __ ] so
i'll be heading back to it so no fast
and furious yet but
in 2021 i promise because
that movie's finally coming this summer
we think allegedly is coming this summer
i am going to watch fast and furious and
me and mark are going to do
fat man beyond colon what was it called
it's fast and victorious yes
[Laughter]
fast and vicarious and i'm doing it kids
just because that's a funny [ __ ]
title
that's why it's worth doing um birthday
show
ladies and gentlemen not mine not marx
jc's birthday man uh you wanna you wanna
wish jc
reifenberg and and the scum and villainy
cantina itself
a happy birthday click on that link
throw them a few shekels and whatnot
i got money sitting here for jay-z i
just ain't seen him in [ __ ] months
man
i'm talking cash not that check [ __ ]
you've got a cash i'm talking
i know i gotta get down to hollywood
again that's true now that i now that
the bar is closed i'm not down there
very often
um what uh how is baby life sir
uh it's good she i was up until
2 a.m last night working on some scum
and villainy stuff
and i went oh god this is going to be
brutal i'm going to have to wake up in
an hour and a half
to change and feed the baby because i
take the overnight shift
and the baby really you do nice nice guy
yeah
because i'm pretty good at waking up
doing what i have to do and then falling
back to sleep
where jen is up and up or cranky
like she needs a lot more sleep than i
do but last night
jocelyn slept for nine straight hours
she slept from 9 30 p.m till 7 30 this
morning
so that was yeah if you're in the
audience and you're like
is that a good thing i sleep for nine
hours all the time um
because you've never had a baby that is
a massive thing
like a wonderful thing for new parents
particularly because kids don't like to
sleep that often nine
hours that's great yeah it's a point
that like she's been
so good with sleep and everybody's like
are you exhausted yet i was like no no
i'm not
that i started googling if she would
like had a problem like if your seven
week old baby is sleeping more
than eight hours at a time is something
wrong with her
and everybody's like no something's
wrong with you for complaining about it
um i wanted to shout out uh hayden
is the other guy on cobra kai uh well
it's hey
losberg who are the other two john
hurwitz
uh is the main guy those guys have each
directed 10 episodes
uh and then there's a jennifer saloda
and josh
heald have each done six episodes i
think it's
uh hurwitz what's the other name
schlossberg
and i think healed was their third like
in the created
three games um it's uh they're doing the
lord's work i met them at
uh um san diego comic-con back when we
had that sort of thing
and uh when i was on the imd boat
interviewing people
and stuff and uh i interviewed the cast
and i
[ __ ] just waxed waxed on and waxed
off all over them and [ __ ] about how
much i love the show
and so the creators were there and you
know they were like oh my god [ __ ]
like we
couldn't believe how much you love that
i was are you kidding me [ __ ] this
show's gold
so i'm so happy for that man this is a
town where it's very easy
not to be happy for the success of
others particularly when
sometimes the others are like real
horrible people and [ __ ]
but you know i this show i wish everyone
the [ __ ] best i hope they keep making
this
for [ __ ] years and sh i hope they
keep making it until
uh ralph macchio is as old as as pat
morita was and i think he is by the
by now he might be i think he is
actually the age pat morita is and so
how they weave miyagi in there and the
mythos of miyagi
when they don't have pat morita to play
with is
expert like he's you know he obviously
he passed away but he's in every episode
of the show
and his presence is felt in every
episode of the show oh
you know it's oh the show i'm telling
you it's a cry fest for me because i'm
like it's that
wonderfully cheesy kind of storytelling
where you're like like the end of
episode
[ __ ] one you know i'm not gonna spoil
it but everybody's seen the trailer and
[ __ ] so they know
[ __ ] works out for one of the characters
but you knew it was coming
and still it was set up so perfectly and
the
you know one kid's in a [ __ ] coleman
he keeps
in the coma he's in a match like where
he's fighting somebody and
somebody keeps beating him and stuff and
he's faintly hearing
voices from the real world but they you
know
i'm gonna cry it's so good of course
it's [ __ ] johnny's voice that like
connects with him and i was like
oh so [ __ ] good it's it's a wonderful
show
um all right let's dive in to the news
shall we mark bernard and you don't [ __ ]
around it's maybe a new year maybe 2021
and he may be a [ __ ] uh a writer
professional writer paid to give you
entertainments
but uh he also knows how to do the news
he sniffs out some [ __ ] news and he's
ready to snort the [ __ ] news this
week do some bumps
some rails news uh ladies and gentlemen
uh mark bernard with the news what news
we got um we have
you know it's it's oh wait we didn't
talk about seoul
well we'll we'll get to it after the
news because i got my top 12
and so we can uh oh [ __ ] sweet all
right so no questions we got top 12 this
week yeah well we'll see how long this
all takes
um but the news the news
it's always a thin news week the week
between christmas and new year's
but because wonder woman 84 dropped on
hbo max
and did pretty well all things
considered
how do we know that i mean i'm not
doubting it but what's the metric for
really well
um the metric um seems to be
um subscribers and how many of the
subscribers actually
watched and so warner brothers reported
that nearly half of hbo max's retail
subscriber walked wonder woman 84 on
business day
so that's good so that's good um that
you know there's been some retention
there was a couple surveys done saying
that you know like 23 percent of the
people
had signed up for it simply because of
wondering 84 and like
uh 19 or 20 percent decided to
remain subscribers after watching wonder
woman 1984
all of which is good news for warner
brothers um
and it did open in some theaters like it
was in you know
some 2100 theaters in in in the states
and
across the world and in the weeks since
it's been opened it's
the worldwide total is 100 million
dollars it made a hundred million
dollars
around the world which you know uh
is a huge [ __ ] figure one of these
sorry thank you um a huge [ __ ] figure
i wish i could make a hundred million
dollars doing anything but
wonder woman would have made 200 million
in america
opening weekend if there had been no
such thing of covets so
this is great [ __ ] covert number and
whatnot and something they were prepared
for warner brothers not sitting there
going
how did this happen like you know
they're that's still the highest
grossing film of the quarantine i think
right
um well still worldwide pulled in 362
million dollars
um it's been in theaters for
five months you know which is longer
than your average movies in theaters
um and it did get to play overseas
before
you know europe and asia began its
own shutdowns and reopening processes
but it's and it's a far sight from the
2017 gross of the first one which was
822 million dollars
but it's pretty good given where we are
and when we are um
and on the heels of that um warner
brothers you know
made the no-brainer announcement that
they're going to make a third wonder
woman movie
and they've played i thought that was
adorable
where they were like this movie's done
so good we guess what
now we've decided to make a third one
it's like come on
i know um you know that
and patty jenkins is returning to direct
and to right
um gal gadot will be back the the the
press release was very specific and
saying
they will return to conclude the long
planned theatrical trilogy
they they were not in any way you know
pretending
that oh you don't know one of them in
1992
is going to be on hbo max first they're
like no they were like you know
well we don't know if we're gonna keep
going with this wonder woman thing
right um so yeah they they're saying
it's theatrical they're they're
doubling down on their desire to nurture
the theatrical business if and when it
returns
back to its robustness um the the thing
that's unclear is
when in patty jenkins's upcoming um time
slot
103 will be because she's already done
committed to rogue squadron for
lucasfilm
and disney so is wrong squadron gonna be
first is one number three gonna be first
nobody knows nobody knows but hey we get
two more movies from patty jenkins which
is not a bad thing
um wonder woman uh still dividing
audiences um for as much as i enjoyed it
i've seen many people
who are like you're a [ __ ] crybaby
idiot who enjoys everything
and they're they're not wrong mark my
bar is
is very low when it comes to stuff like
that but
i still feel feel the movie's good man i
went back and rewatched
my favorite parts um before i started
writing my own thing
um and uh you know the the cheetah fight
even as cg as it is
i still i love it i'm like i can't
believe i lived long enough
where i saw [ __ ] wonder woman fight
cheetah in real life like this is
[ __ ] nuts
so um but then right after the cheetah
fight is where i
drop out because that's when that's when
she sits on the floor for the third act
and says you know nice things very nice
things but
um i was glad we have to cheat a fight
because
i watched uh hbo max now has the first
couple seasons of wonder woman
on there like the le carter wonder woman
so i i watched
uh i got like an operator pilot which is
so [ __ ] daffy
because the first two acts there's no
diana in it it is literally just steve
trevor and
nazis like all about these [ __ ] nazis
well think about it you're you're doing
a tv show in the 70s
so they're like nobody's gonna [ __ ]
tune in just
if we show them a woman right in the
first frame they'll go running what is
this a soap opera
so you know they were like let's get
some action in there steve trevor taking
on nazis
so that your dad would sit there and
watch it
and then once you know they didn't then
they'd be hooked because they're
watching an action thing
and then suddenly they get to paradise
island it was not themselves
and you get to paradise ireland and so
your dad would be like look at all these
women and [ __ ] i like this show
i could see that that would make sense
that's not what i would do but it seems
like a 70s approach to telling the story
it very much does you know and and but i
remember watching it with
my son who's like when does wonder woman
show up in the wonder woman show
i'm like that's a fair point buddy i'm
not sure
and then you get to paradise island and
it's just like a lingerie catalog
because nobody's wearing full clothes so
here's diana running on the beach with a
friend and it's like why are you wearing
a nightie
paint this is so weird and glorified
paradise island mark paradise
yes that's what paradise is who knew
that like they predicted
one day we'd all be running around in
our [ __ ] pjs and [ __ ] because nobody
leaves their houses anymore
but the best part is flores lipscombe
plays her brother and cloris leachman
clearly is only just she got a script
and she's saying all the words in the
script but she's making
every choice when it comes to playing
her mother because there's times when
she just like
she's well done no we you can't be his
nurse and she's
staring at this [ __ ] apple as if the
secret to the universe is in it and then
she just popped
her over shoulder picks up another one
and she's like
no daddy you can't be his nurse and then
there's a brazer with smoke in it and
she starts
lounging on it like she must have just
been
we're not directing her she's doing
whatever she wants to do but she's
saying all the words in the script so we
can't
cut so and it's clara's [ __ ] leachman
okay what was it did they call her
hippolyta no
no no it's just like mother you never
actually give her a name
um but i i highly recommend going back
to the historical artifact that is the
wonder woman pilot and just marveling at
all of it um because it's kind of
amazing in chat molly ringworm said
still not as bad as catwoman 2004
that is fair um
yeah we see you in chat and everybody's
saying uh
like who is it wanna beatles says cloris
leachman was miscast in the pilot
episode
oh yes but it's hilarious because she's
in a completely different show
but saying the lines that belong in this
one
um i have not uh
looked at that in a in a while i'm
re-watching over on hollywood uh babylon
we're doing the caped commentaries
where i'm watching uh um every episode
of
batman 66 with ralph we just finished up
season one
we're gonna do the movie and then head
into season two
uh coming up this year and stuff but uh
you know that one
that one i you know is is more my speed
i just remember as a kid as
even though i watched wonder woman every
week there was
you know i was like come on get out of
the army clothes put on your outfit
see a costume stay in the costume even
if you're just
not doing anything important just
superhero costume
um the the the next
and last news story is again it's a
skinny week
um but it does panel thing with that
first one which is um
the dc films plan going forward um
walter hamana who's the the dc films
president
um there was a big profile on him in the
new york times and he sort of confirmed
what their plan was
um for their upcoming dc slate
and the the the big at least to me
surprise was not that we're going to get
more wonder woman and not
that march is going to be when justice
league director's cut um
the zack snyder comes out but how their
march marches the snyder cup marches
this niner cut
um don't know when in march but but
march um
but the the decision on on warner
brothers and dc films is part
to bifurcate the way they're going to be
releasing films because they now have to
feed hbo max
as a very real part of their ongoing
strategy
so for them uh the most expensive dt
movies will be designed for movie
theaters as they always have been like
wonder woman
and aquaman and the aquaman sequel and
and
the rocks black adam film and this
flash movie um whenever that happens um
and so they want to be releasing four of
those movies a year
starting in 2022. um what does what was
marvel doing before
you know we all had to go inside marvel
was at its
max three movies a year i think there
were there were some years where you
only got two you got one
in the summer and one in in sort of fall
christmasy
um i think in the game year
we got three um
but yeah three seems to be the most that
they did four is very ambitious
um while also similarly putting
a couple of um smaller riskier comic
book films
on hbo max and so the plan is
six movies a year i'm i'm down with this
plan
um i i am too in theory and some of it
is just me having to i guess
get out of my head that there there is
any real difference anymore between what
goes in theaters and what goes on hbo
max
because you know for them the the idea
of their smaller riskier movies
are things like batgirl and static shop
um both of which don't seem like they're
risky to me
those don't seem risky at all so if you
were gonna do a jonah hex movie that
seems risky
right you know it's it's what they're
deciding
is risky and it's like oh the one about
the the ladies and the one about the
black people are the ones that we are
not
sure would work in theaters despite the
abundance of
evidence particularly with their own
company with with wonder woman like you
know from them i'm like you know from
the studio that brought you wonder woman
batgirl here we go yeah
for sure um and given that black panther
is the single highest solo grossing
superhero movie
ever um and spider-verse made
a bunch of money and won a bunch of
oscars and now you wouldn't think that
they're similar upside to static
um there's a little boggling mind
particularly if you're going to tie it
into like the dc universe in some way
you know in the comics they rarely did
that there was like a crossover i think
once or something but milestone
was in its own universe but if they in
the movies they don't have to
abide by that they could totally [ __ ]
throw you know
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] aquaman or whatever
the [ __ ] like
you know throw it in there make it
interesting for cats who are like who is
this new character but
like some cats felt that way about black
panther at one point who is this new
character who
wasn't new at all but somebody every
comic book or as
stan lee told us every comic book or to
paraphrase every comic book movie
is somebody's first comic book and or
comic book movie so
yeah you're right man that should be
theatrical yeah but i just
make more like i'm i'm glad that they're
leaning into you know what seems like
the marvel plan we're gonna make movies
and we're gonna make tv shows i mean
suicide squad
has already has a spin-off with
peacemaker mm-hmm
gonna be amazing you know and the batman
already has its own spin-off like
they're also very much mindful of
not only do we need to put movies in
theaters and movies on any of your match
but now we got to spin off these movies
into their own
companion tv shows and if they're smart
they'll make them like marvel seems to
be
making you know by all rumors and
reports
like did you see the the this isn't news
but it's more rumor
um that uh um what's his name [ __ ]
uh sherlock doctor strange um
cumberbatch is uh reportedly
showing up in wanda vision which makes
sense
because the very next movie is
doctor strange multiverse madness that
and the storyline is going to continue
into there
so it's one thing to be like hey we got
a show
it's another thing for that show
to be a bridge between sequels you know
what i'm saying or other movies or
something
and it sounds like maybe dc get ready to
do that themselves
um kevin pender is asking no hidalgo
news did you follow that story at all
not really that was the the star wars
media
like social media guy was in pablo
hidalgo or whatever yeah who apparently
made a joke about
like you know somebody put up the thing
about like they cried
watching the final episode of the
mandalorian which
i co-signed so did i and [ __ ] um i'm on
record crying about everything so
uh this this cat said this and put it in
a tweet or whatever
tweeted up the link of him actually
watching it and crying
and um i guess this cat
hidalgo was like retweeted it and said
something like you know you're not
you shouldn't show your feelings or like
no you're not allowed to show your
feelings or i don't know
but it clearly wasn't [ __ ] serious
didn't seem serious
and then uh like uh i guess a bunch of
twitter
blew up at him because he works in
lucasfilm or for lupus film
and so a bunch of people were saying
like what the [ __ ] man like this is
another instance of like lucasfilm just
[ __ ] on the fan base and whatnot
from i didn't go any deeper than like
looking at the tweet jc probably might
have
a little more info he's our resident
star wars guy at this point but
from what i read it didn't seem like all
that bad jc do you know more about this
story
i mean i think that's basically it i
think
you know uh pablo was one of the like
very strong last jedi supporters
when all that was going on and got real
uh vocal about
uh with fans that didn't like that movie
and who were vocal about not liking the
movie
so in the chat isaac ruggles is saying
pablo crapped all over
star wars theory one of the biggest star
wars
fans on youtube um the youtube shows uh
youtuber with star wars theory do you
know star wars are you familiar with it
um
i've watched some of his stuff he's a
canadian guy he's got about half a
million subscribers so
he's big but i didn't see i didn't see
what pablo
you see me light up when he said
canadian i was a canadian guy
well you know what you know yeah you
know he's a nice guy
you know yeah exactly that's cool and
also like i bet i co-signed like the
dude putting up a video of him crying at
that episode of the mandalorian
i'm sorry you'd have to be a [ __ ]
robot not to cry or feel something at
that last episode if you grew up [ __ ]
watching
luke skywalker and [ __ ] like that so
like you know he was completely in the
right
um star wars theory and i don't think it
doesn't sound like
like pablo was in the wrong it just
sounded like he made a joke on twitter
that
[ __ ] lap reported i think it looks
weird because
after all the last jedi stuff pablo
made his twitter private and i think he
was making
a joke very tongue-in-cheek um and look
like
i'm on record as not loving last jedi um
so i if i thought that pablo was being a
jerk
just correct cause you're getting
attacked and oh
he has uh almost three million
subscribers
okay well maybe what was your number
half a million yeah they were all over
you on that one
[ __ ] you jc he's got three million so
he's very popular
um yeah we've only got half a million on
this one
maybe i was just trying to make us feel
better
now you're making me feel bad but uh you
know
look if i thought he was actually being
if you want to roll back and watch pablo
be a jerk
roll back to december 2017. i don't
think this was
was that when last year what why so what
did he do during that point
anybody who is like last jedi sucks he's
like you
suck you don't know anything about star
wars pablo
is um lucasfilm's story team and he's
also
i mean he goes deep he knows star wars
he wrote a lot of those old
west end games star wars role-playing
that was he's he knows everything about
star wars like he's the guy who like
made up a lot of that
backstory um but i don't think this
was i think this is people looking for
for a fight maybe with just cause
because
of things he said in the past but i
don't think that this was actually
uh him inciting trouble
sith kill uh 308 in the chat says
he posted on his twitter after all that
drama
as retired um after all of it
and he did apologize and everyone still
attacked him
yeah he did i mean he apologized john
martin's on twitter said it didn't
really seem like
much of a joke i mean why would he just
emotions are not for sharing that's what
he wrote
and then uh old school shinobi says
emotions are not for sharing my god what
a way to crap on fans give me a break
i don't know the guy or anything but i
didn't read that
as like this is crapping on fans i
didn't and he was responding
to somebody who said i believe he
he responded to somebody else's tweet
that was like look at this
kid crying about star wars get out of
your mom's basement
or something that was a little more a
little more combative or something yeah
pablo said
emotions are not to be shared i don't
think
that sounded like a i know it's not a
quote from anything but it sounded very
jedi or sith like i thought he was
making a star wars funny
it's to me it almost sounded like
i don't think he was validating the guy
the guy's tweet who was
[ __ ] on star wars theory but i could
also understand why it would seem that
way because he has a private twitter
and he put it up as his banner image
afterwards
which he explained that's what sean m
says
pablo hidalgo uh made it his twitter
banner to shame star wars theory
it's a lot of drama going on here what
pablo said which
i believe more than the shame is
i got that he was getting attacked and
he said i put it
up there so that because i have a
private twitter
so that people didn't think i was trying
to hide something
so that they could see it without me
making my twitter public for everybody
again
which i think you know sounds a lot more
reasonable than like hey i'm an
executive at lucasfilm and i'm gonna
double down on crapping on the fans when
i got called out for it
like i don't know
also like why are we fighting like
everybody loves mandalorian let's just
talk about that why are we supposed to
die like [ __ ] mandalorian ended
one week and [ __ ] everyone's back at
each other's throats man
like i just don't get it yeah
fat black patrick swayze in the twitch
says i feel like everyone is
in this thing is getting butt hurt i'm
sorry
we have to pause to just
go back to the name real quick i'm sorry
uh
yeah he's one of our twitch watchers
he's here every week fat
black patrick swayze fantastic name
instantly evokes an image that's a
writer
ladies and gentlemen uh but yeah he
thinks that people are getting butt hurt
over mixed messages and i think that's
what it is i think it's mixed messages
on the internet i don't agree with you
everything on the internet is always
[ __ ] clear and stuff um and then uh
someone else asked in chat like nothing
about ray fisher
uh there was no real i mean i guess
ray fisher announced that he would not
be working with
um any of his mother walter after the
walter hamada article came out
because i believe walter hamada was one
of the people that he
did he signal him out along with jeff
johns and stuff like that john burke
yeah
and john burke so he he announced that
he won't be making any movies
over there is that that's the news he he
drew a line in the stand
which uh apparently everybody's
respecting
um i yeah there's not much more news
beyond that
um i still keep waiting for for the
the specific list of ray fisher
grievances
you know like there's there's a lot of
they know what they did
but nobody else knows what they did um
and so it's
i i find it just personally it's
beginning to
to blur into the din of the background
without any real specificity
offered by either party so other than we
start an investigation
and the biggest question though is if
if ray is saying that does that mean
he's not going to be in the flash movie
um
maybe he was never going to be in the
flash movie i don't know
you know like at this point he's
definitely not because he made a big
statement saying that he's not going to
do anything else but i don't know what
the plan was for cyborg in the flash
movie
um you know but
who the hell knows who the hell knows um
and bunny and chat goes meanwhile in the
real world
i'm like home we're not there pat
this is here stay away from the real
world and stuff gonna start paying
attention to the real world in about 20
days
but yeah this is for now this is our
safe space real world
unless something just broke while we
were doing the show
there's no reason to talk about current
events we're talking about current
pop cultural events ladies and gentlemen
we are and and the desire for
dc to double down on the multiverse
in that there's gonna be two different
batman film franchises
starring two different batmen at the
same time
like robert pattinson is in the dc films
multiverse but his batman does not exist
in the dc
extended universe so like his batman
will not cross over with gal gadot or or
that makes sense i mean i'm not saying
that that's the way it should be but i
guess that makes
sense ben is still batman in the
snyder verse um and the dc
eu um right and he is like he's batman
like
you know uh um joaquin phoenix was the
joker
in standalones that will never cross
over with
the others right so like you know
that's fair i'm not like you know
[ __ ] upset about that i'm like i get
it that's fair
yeah i mean i i get it because they
they're trying to you know
have their cake and eat it too which is
a dumb sentence because if you have your
cake of course you can eat it but
whatever
um but but the the we're gonna have an
earth too
and the earth 1 and an earth 3 and we
get as many arts as we want to make room
for all of these different kind of
things
and somehow knit it together into a
giant story that makes some sense you
know why you know why i'm giving you
thumbs up because do that for a couple
years and then people are going to be
like we need to
bring the multiverse into a universe and
then we get a [ __ ] crisis
big ass crisis man [ __ ]
expensive ass with big explosions and
[ __ ] like that
yeah i mean and so they're they're
betting on it you know hamada said
audiences are sophisticated enough to
understand it if we make good movies
they'll go with it
um uh entree humane on on
on the chat said tv already made a solid
take on the multiverse
they better earn that movies for it to
work i i mean
i don't think like i love what they've
done on tv but
it wasn't like they slowly did it over
time like one day on one of the shows
and it was probably [ __ ] flash
they were like multiverse and then
suddenly that was it like
and then they started letting them cross
over and [ __ ] like that but it's not
like
it organically and like oh my god it was
so
well crafted like one day they just
introduced it on one of the shows
and then another show was like oh we can
use that so we can cross these shows
over and [ __ ] like that
the original plan was to never do any of
that [ __ ] when they started with arrow
they were like we don't want to be
smallville they were like no air cannons
no [ __ ] fake metal and [ __ ] just a
dude with arrows
like no superhero stuff and then once
flash was introduced
slowly they kind of ah maybe we could do
this maybe we could do that
but yeah you know i think the movies
could pull off multiverse
and i think you could do it in one movie
i think flash this flash movie sounds
like it's going to establish it look
[ __ ] spider-man into the spider-verse
established the multiverse so [ __ ]
well for the mainstream consumer
that they're [ __ ] tripling down on it
and the new spider-man 3
is like [ __ ] set in the multiverse
from what we're understanding so
i mean the trick is that we've never had
to
deal with more than one jane bond at a
time
you've never had to deal with more than
one doctor strange at a time
like it's here's the guy who's playing
the thing and you understand that and
every time we see that character is
going to be that person
and so now dc is attempting to get a
mainstream audience to understand
oh no in this one it's
ben affleck but in that one it's
pattinson and in this one the joker
joker's played by jared
leto but in that one he's played by by
joaquin phoenix
and so just hoping that an audience to
hamada's
to use his work sophisticated enough to
roll with this
in a big way is is a gamble
but you know 14 favors the bold i
suppose
i will point out as a stickler that
there was at one point two james bonds
when uh when sean connery was in never
say never again
and roger moore was in i don't know
octopussy or whatever [ __ ] living
or live and let did not live and like um
yeah i think it was i think it was
octopussy
or maybe a view to a kill but there were
like two of them out at the same time
like which was mind-bending to my father
because my father loved sean connery so
he was like what
and me i was like he was like we're
gonna see james bond and i'm like saint
james bond
like roger moore's james bond
uh all right we hit all the news that's
all the news um
just about the last little bit is that
uh as for the snyder cut
um dc films told the the the
the times that that is a storytelling
cul-de-sac a street that leads nowhere
wait in other words dc films told the
new york times
that the hbo max event the snyder cut is
a storytelling cul-de-sac a street that
leads nowhere
in other words the snyder cut is not
part of the dc films blueprint that's
been discussed here
um just that curiosity why would you
say that why would one feel the need to
put that out there
before this thing even happens because
what if it
you know [ __ ] takes the world by
storm in march
and people are like we want [ __ ] more
and [ __ ] well they're saying like
no there won't be more because i happen
to know that the ending
that he's got for the snyder cut
is very not much
not a cul-de-sac um it takes it to a
weird neighborhood but it's not a
cul-de-sac you can keep [ __ ] going
with the story based on what i've heard
um from from so
it's weird also given the fact that most
of the actors who are in the main line
dc
eu came from that you know since you're
not going to recast jason momoa you're
not going to be cast
gal gadot you know there's going to be
more batman
um who knows i still i still i'm i'm
uncertain about edgar miller
going forward even though warner
brothers seems you know locked and
loaded and ready to go with him
so there's always going to be a strain
of the snyder verse because these are
the actors who populated it
um but whether or not they're going to
give zach more license to make
more justice league movies i think is
the
maybe not but again
like why say that now like i would hedge
my bets
and wait until march and the tale was
told
you know because that way if if the
audience let the audience decide like if
the audience is like we want
[ __ ] more man then you'd you know you
you don't have to go back on what you
said like apparently it's not a
cul-de-sac let's keep going
yeah unless it was all a well-designed
pr ploy to get restore the snyder verse
trending
um which it was over the weekend in the
in the sort of the post
the halcyon blow of this interview
coming out there was a lot of people who
would like to restore the snyder verse
we want more of this like
don't put it in a cul-de-sac there's a
lot more story to tell oh so wait it
wasn't so
the the hashtag was not release the
snyder cut it's restore the snyder verse
yep i mean those cats got a lot
accomplished with the release the snyder
cut [ __ ]
hashtag so if i was if i was warner
brothers i'd i'd
i pay attention yeah unless
if this was warner brothers plan the
entire time which was to put out some
incendiary piece of
information and then just throw the pot
of fandom and then reap the rewards when
the time comes
insidious if that's yeah if they're
playing three-dimensional chess like
that
power to you if they are playing
three-dimensional chess like that that
is why
like i'm stuck where i am in life and no
more successful than i am because i
didn't even see that ploy
all right you got a list do you have
your your time i got i got a list i got
a list and it is less top 10 movies
and it is now uh the top 12 things i saw
on a screen
in 2020 fair enough because there was
not
the the volume of movies we usually get
um
the tv we got was great but also weird
and that there was no real fault season
the way we
normally get it um there are still some
things i haven't seen
so i haven't seen um one night in miami
with the regina kings
um is that on amazon yet not yet i think
it's
it's it's maybe in a week week and a
half or so the 15th it might
um premiere but that's the muhammad ali
malcolm x
sam cook um and
another person whose name i'm forgetting
fictional story but like a what-if story
right well i mean i think there was one
night where all four of these men were
in the same place at the same time
oh so this is like an imagining of that
right like
we know they were all here we know that
some of them have crossed paths but what
is that one night that they all hung out
together how did that
sort of spin forward into the future and
this is regina king's
directorial debut yeah based on a play
um and so i'm curious to see that ma
rainey's black bottom i still haven't
seen yet the uh
the august wilson adaptation with chad
rick boseman's final
screen performance i haven't seen any of
um steve mcqueen's small acts film
series on amazon
he made five movies that are all kind of
about the british
black experience um starring john boyega
and leticia wright and a bunch of other
um
astonishing actors haven't seen it
because five films is
like that you're sitting down and
investing um
on the bubble things that didn't quite
make the 12
craft country um i think it started
going incredibly well but over the
course of it
i began the i was less solid with it
um but that premiere episode i think is
still one of the best things i've saw
all year
and then towards the end of it it just
got blurry to me
and i loved it i loved it i'm surprised
that it didn't make your top ten but
that means you must have a very strong
top ten yeah you know
i hope i do um and then the other thing
on the bubble is soul
which i saw um the day after christmas
and
liked quite a bit but it didn't it
didn't do the thing that i
turned to pixar for which is break my
heart in a way that i didn't quite see
it coming
um you know and all of my favorite pixar
movies make me cry
in some fashion or another because they
they managed to
you know penetrate to this level of
human
emotion that you know and some of it is
because of animation so it is because
the storytelling is so crystal clear
um and the characterizations are so
strong
that uh that that it makes it undeniable
and i didn't cry
and i was like well yeah
no no you can't break my heart there
were
there were definitely some moments where
i teared up and whatnot but there was
there was no
you know bing bong moment from in and
out um
it's not and that's you know no not
everything has to be some other [ __ ]
wonderful movie and stuff
but um it it i loved it i thought it was
incredibly well made but i too
felt like oh all right
and then when it when it ended i was
really surprised because
i they i mean do we want to i don't want
to
i don't know i mean we don't have to
spoil it but i will say i wanted there
to be another scene or two at the end
of seoul that if you're not going to do
the premise of the
movie which is here's a guy jazz
musician who dies
goes to heaven tries to or goes to the
limbo between
you know earth and heaven and tries to
earn his way back to earth because he's
got unfinished business um
and there's a version of that movie you
know which we
not to say we have we've seen before but
there have been other movies about
the the go-between you know defending
your life
amongst one of the most famous ones
about like you know this is a guy who's
dead
and the movie's not about him getting
his life back it's about him being okay
with being dead and realizing that it's
not the end of his story
and there's a version of soul that is
100 that
um but that's not the version you get um
the felony chris and chat said the
people who
lost their purpose made him cry i
thought that was really touching like
the big
things that just like [ __ ] grazed and
ran around and [ __ ] like that
yeah um section 8 zed said soul is sad
for me because i lost a child
oh my god that's so sad yeah i mean i
think
i've spoken to people for whom it's very
affecting but i think
my kid [ __ ] called me at midnight
from dallas
and was like you have to watch she was
[ __ ] bawling she's like you have to
watch soul
so i was going to watch seoul anyway and
[ __ ] but like you know that kind of
review
i'm like look she she reacts like me to
everything so if she's [ __ ] got a
good cry on
i'm gonna get good cry on and i thought
it was wonderful
and definitely there were some moments
that made me choke up but i did not
like i you know it didn't like in and
out in and out was uh
inside out kevin kline oh my god
or in and out that i wish i could be
eating um inside out
destroyed me and there are a lot of pigs
so what's another really fun what was
the one
up up broke me the first 10 minutes of
up are you the same first [ __ ] few
minutes of bop you're already like
so yeah but this was really well done
um but yeah just it didn't it didn't
[ __ ] make me
uh cry you said something before we
started the show about
something i didn't know about the first
incarnation
yeah and the the the the co-director and
the co-writer
on seoul um got in kent powers
was a somewhat late addition to it there
was a version of seoul that had been
going at pixar which was
uh from what i understand about an anime
and so it was about an animator yeah
and so all of the the representations
that you see in in
the limbo feel very like squiggly lines
very abstract very like
very drawy very painfully very artistic
and then i think at some point they
decided to make a shift so it was going
to be
a about jazz and b about the black
experience to a certain degree in
americans but a black guy
so maybe you know we should bring in a
black guy and so
all of the earth stuff feels very it
struck me very much like spider-verse
in that it's about being black
without being about being black you know
like his life was very much like oh i'm
gonna teach these kids and i'm gonna go
to the barber shop and go to this jazz
club
i'm gonna go to these historically black
faces and just back where the drama will
be
and i love that part of it so it's so
weird when it shifts
into like a heavenly space it's like
well this is just
odd and like doesn't feel like a part of
the same movie
and reznor and atticus ross are doing
the score for a movie about jazz
like they did another score recently
that was just like them
oh uh uh mank they did the score for
that and it doesn't sound anything like
you know always a musician you could do
a lot of things but he does
when you hear trent resner you don't
hear the score to mankind your head but
now that will change
and when you hear trent reznor you don't
think of the score to soul but that will
change as the dude continues to [ __ ]
expand his
horizons and whatnot but yeah i i
i i hadn't thought about that aspect of
it the uh i'm i was very delighted to
hear
uh my friend donnell rawlings and he was
the barber
um hair um and it's you know any time
like jason lee was in a pixar movie and
i was like anytime you know somebody in
pixar movie it's just like oh my god
good for you
that's [ __ ] get into that world get
your foot in that [ __ ] door and stuff
well-acted jamie foxx is great tina fey
is
great um across the board his old cass
was great
coco that's the movie i was thinking of
oh yes so there's inside out but [ __ ]
coco
is an insanely high bar in terms of if
you're dealing with death
um and in coco death was death
um nobody reversed it and [ __ ] like that
so
you know that's hello miguel the kid
does get to go back he dies to go and
talk
and then he gets to cross the bridge and
go back home
um but you know and the thing that i
wanted from from seoul
was the thing that you also got from
coco which was a universal story
seen through the very specific cultural
lens like it's a story about missing
people and about wanting people back
but it's pulled through this lens of of
mexican folklore and day of the dead and
all of that stuff which is beautiful and
gorgeous and lovely and for like a bunch
of people who are not part of the
culture
was new so like sitting there watching a
movie like is that what it's like
like it's not only entertaining but it's
it's educational
yeah and you get you get to to play in
in an arena that is both
fantastical and wonderful if you're not
familiar with it and completely reverent
to it
if you are and so i was hoping that
seoul would have had a little bit more
of that
where it was oh okay so this is what
this experience this is what heaven
looks like to this particular
black jazz musician and what that means
and how that's culturally
um reminiscent of what his mother felt
about when his father died about what
you know
all of it like maybe make it part of the
fabric and it didn't
which i was a little disappointed by um
all of which is to say
it's still like solid upper middle tier
pixar like it's not a misfire in any way
because it's gorgeous and and and fun if
you've got disney plus it's free as [ __ ]
it's freezing they didn't move on this
[ __ ] lord they're like char give us a
little more they just put it up there
for nothing
just put it up there um so those were
the two that that that sort of just
missed out making it in there
i i'm not surprised about uh um
seoul but i am surprised that uh
lovecraft didn't make it into the top
10.
your reasons are valid and i'm not
shaming i was just like wow that was
definitely if i had a 10 that'd be
in mine all right let's let's hear your
ten starting from ten working down to
one yeah
well we're doing 12. um i found it hard
um number 12 is the game for the
playstation 4 called ghosts of tashima
which was a a samurai
kind of open world thing but it's about
a guy who's trying to live up to
his uncle's vision for what his future
should be
who discovers a different path in life
and it is
gorgeous i mean it's all feel japan and
it's all like
you know lilies and grassy fields and
beautifully rendered armor and the story
is elemental and it's
simple and it's and it was one of the
more fun experiences i had
um matching of working
buttons um this year on a video game
console
number 11 is the
the west wing did a live reading
of an older episode called hearts build
landing um
and it was basically staged as a
fundraiser for um
for the biden campaign and i my love for
the west wing goes deep and i've talked
about it here
a bunch of times i'm sure um
but to just see that cast get together
again and to see them do that thing that
they do
um it was part of part of the unifying
theme of
this list this year is things that made
me feel good
at a time when i was searching for
things to make me feel good
um and so that is very much checking of
that box
number ten um the five bloods
spike lays netflix movie i'm starring
delray lindell
sorry i muted myself uh i still haven't
seen it
um how good is it um it's really really
good
it's really really good i mean it's very
spike you know and so there's a moment
where you're like oh yeah there's a
spikey movie here's where your
protagonist is on a dolly being pulled
through the scene and
here's here's a lot of mixed media
sort of documentary kind of teaching
storytelling
but it's it's incredibly effective and
spike does a lot with a little
because you could tell that he had like
a 50 million dollar budget and he's got
to somehow recreate
the vietnam war um and he does so
and and and it's also about fathers and
sons starring co-starring jonathan
majors
the lead of love this is the first place
i saw him
uh oh really he's the he's the star um
he's the
he's the one of the co-stars he's
remembered correctly
del roy lindo's son um and del orlando
great
like you know classic [ __ ] spikey
actor
um titan of american stage and scream
um so to watch him just threat out and
lean in
to play a a black dude wearing a mega
hat
and have compelling reasons why
is that is kind of fun um so number nine
high fidelity
um which was the uh the zoe kravitz
reboot refresh of you know
geez you know twice before told story
more of the nick hornsby book right do
they go they lean more toward the book
than the movie
yeah they lean back towards it but you
still get these moments
you know that are evocative of moments
you remember from both the book and the
movie
but sort of subverted in ways to make it
enjoyable if you're familiar intimately
so with both of them
and you know this was the first time i'd
really seen zoe kravitz
and i was like oh no now i get it like
now i understand
you know she'd always been you know
fun you know but i've never seen her get
to stretch really and i was never a
um what was the big little live i never
watched that so i was never like that
person
um so this was my first time going oh
[ __ ] yeah i get it
she's very good in it but that's like a
big ensemble she's like one
of many in that it seems like with high
fidelity she got to she's the star she
got to shine
yeah she got the shirt so so i was sad
that we didn't get to see more of that
yeah they can't do that unfortunately
yeah they did
because hulu i i think that was part of
those things where it was owned by
another studio and hulu
then got blocked by disney and some
things just didn't make it
through the the transfer i think that
was one of them
um number eight is hamilton
which was on the disney flutes i still
haven't i mean i saw hamilton
on broadway but i still haven't watched
the disney plus version
now did you ever see the show or you
just listened to the soundtrack
um i listened to the soundtrack much
more than i saw the show i did see it
twice in l.a
but i never saw the original cast and so
the this is your
cast is davey diggs in it david diggs is
in it lynn manuel is in it lego junior
is in it like it's
it was i think in the last month or so
before the original cast began to
dissipate
they captured this and so to get to see
it
with that cast and to get to see it in a
production and in a manner
that brings you inside that show in a
way that you couldn't see
on on in broadway um i know it's
incredibly well done
and that's the only reason why it it
kind of
slides through the the technicality of
no the play
was in whatever like 2016 but
this was the only time you could see it
with these people this year
um that makes it over there um
number seven was the mandalorian um
i uh i i remember feeling underwhelmed
by the beginning of the season
um and my whelmingness began to increase
um as the season went on to the point
where the last
three episodes are just fantastic um
and i guess that's just the pattern this
show is gonna go
it's gonna start kind of small and then
build itself up
and then crescendo and then the season
will start again
and then build itself up to crescendo
and so by the time you got to the end of
the mandalorian
season two it was magical um i just wish
it was magical throughout
um which is the only reason it's halfway
through my my top 12.
still makes the top 12. still makes the
top 12.
um number six is the boys season two
that was wonderful this year so great
so great kripke is [ __ ] i i got to
interview him on the imdb
boat uh probably for the boys i think it
was for the boys before it
aired um and he's a real good dude man
funny dude but also like
really dialed into story and [ __ ] and
that show i mean didn't [ __ ]
barack obama list that as one of the
shows that he loved this year
i love the idea of barack obama watching
homelander masturbate on the city
i'm sure he was like why didn't i try
that [ __ ] man
get on the top of the [ __ ] white
house it is i'm going to be right back
i'm going to uh i'm going to take the
stairs i'm going to go to the roof
and i'm going to masturbate on the rose
garden mark bernardin's barack obama
ladies and gentlemen not that he waited
until
season six to debut
um that delighted me no end when i saw
that show on his list i was like that's
a human being
with class and taste because he don't
have to
include that he don't have to [ __ ] be
like yeah i watch
i watch the boys we [ __ ] owned up to
it he was like yeah i watched the boys
just [ __ ] oh yeah um
and yeah i i i didn't know because i had
stopped reading the book by the time
they introduced stormfront so i didn't
know where that was going
but it was one of those you know and
much like lovecraft who was
credit this this piece of content that
could not have known it was going to be
as relevant as it was when it was
hitting the audience
yes yes yes very much so and like
watchmen
as well like watchmen lovecraft and end
this
i remember watching them and being like
wait
did they just shoot this last week how
do you [ __ ] get this current
um those are magical [ __ ] writers
rooms right there
very much so or maybe it's just that
sadly
the same problems from the past are the
same problems in the present
so they're not magicians they're like
what do you mean it never went away
we're just putting it on [ __ ]
attention
yes we put a [ __ ] lens on it
uh six number five was the last dance
which was the uh the documentary ten
part documentary by espn films
about the chicago bulls basketball thing
the basketball thing about this i
remember this was uh this was during the
beginning of the quarantine
yeah i was like thank god for this it
was all i think it was like june it was
like may or june
um but but it is a bit like
another um entry on this list
not about the sport that it's about as
much as about the people who play that
sport
and the weird psychological profile of
michael jordan and scotty pippen and
dennis rodman
and these outlandish personalities all
of which are driven
all of which are are in some ways
megalomaniacal
for success and how that manifests in
these people um
i found it amazing and how long is it
so it's hard yeah now once and you've
said
that it's more about the people but for
somebody who like
has no familiarity with basketball
than i used to videotape the basketball
games in high school
um is you know 10 hours
long time with someone like myself who
doesn't give a [ __ ] about hoops
be into it you know they do the very
good job that a good documentary about a
specific item
your subject does of contextualizing it
all for you
by using people you may or may not
recognize and my favorite
credit um chiron for an interview
subject is
barack obama former chicago resident
[Laughter]
and so like talking about like using
those people to help explain
like what the bulls meant when they were
making this run
and then also using lots of footage to
talk about who michael jordan was and
his story
and and some of it yes there's a ton of
basketball game footage
but you know they do a decent enough job
of explaining to you
what the stakes are in any one of those
games um and the soundtrack is [ __ ]
nuts
there's uh they had all the mine they
had disney money and so when you get to
have
prince's party man as part of the
soundtrack for a michael jordan
sports documentary it's kind of amazing
they took it from a batman film
yep they paid warner brothers
part of a batman soundtrack and used it
for their basketball thing
and didn't care um all right it's called
the last dance
the last dance that's number five number
four
we talked about on the show the
speedcubers
that lovely little documentary 45
minutes long
about so so
short kids like i'm if you even feel
like i don't like documentaries
this [ __ ] thing will make your heart
soar it was such a great find i
co-signed this with mark
it and again like it's not that like oh
it's short so it's good but like
they got a lot [ __ ] done in 45
minutes
it's so much so that it feels complete
you don't feel like well they should
have went into it more
or this should be a series not it was
absolutely [ __ ] perfect
and a story that you've never seen
before
an incredibly human wonderfully warm
human story that was also competitive
so there's a like quasi-sports
background to it or thread going through
because they are in competition
but how these completely different
people from uh
completely different parts of the world
find each other through
[ __ ] rubik's cube man it's it was
absolutely wonderful but
45 minutes that's it it's not even like
10 episodes or 45 minutes
45 [ __ ] minutes and you're out give
it a shot
kids i just watched this morning i got
up at like four in the morning
and i couldn't sleep and i didn't want
to start writing yet because i knew i
wanted to go back to bed
so i grabbed a smoke and i was just
reading the news and i don't know why
but in my news feed they put up
biography put up a documentary about the
heinz
family you know oh i was like
tap dancing no yeah gregory hines
and his brother um it was about but
heinz you know ketchup heinz 57.
[ __ ] fascinating 45 minutes and i'm
like who knew
like this deep dive history into
condiments but
two things i walked away with it with
number one
the guy heinz like uh you know
he was like a marketer before there was
marketing
so he saw an ad is before the turn of
the century
for like you know uh ladies shoes in 22
uh styles and he liked
that that it was the the number was
memorable and
that it implied that there was a lot and
[ __ ]
so he said to telegram and he was like
put on every bottle from now on 57
varieties because it'll indicate how
many different products we make
and they were like we make more than 57
we make over 60 at this point
and he goes just put 57 because it's a
memorable number and lodges in people's
heads
and so they marketed on this number that
he just picked
that wasn't even accurate and it became
for a long time the nickname the moniker
most people didn't call it ketchup they
called it heinz 57 and [ __ ]
um and then the other thing i found
[ __ ] fascinating
um well one side note anyone who gets
rich
apparently they ignore the [ __ ] out of
their kids because this whole thing was
about how
this guy was a billionaire and he was
amazing with his staff
he built the [ __ ] people who worked
in his factory
a swimming pool a rooftop garden to hang
out
in and a huge [ __ ] cafeteria where
they had live music playing whenever
they ate every day and [ __ ] so he was
like way ahead of the curve
in terms of taking care of employees and
he was like uh affable and they could
all talk to him and [ __ ] like that
but with his own kids he was all cold
and distant [ __ ]
and each one of the kids then goes on to
like run the company when the previous
cat dies and [ __ ] so ketchup
this story of ketchup blew my [ __ ]
mind
in england they had this [ __ ] called cat
sup
you know we've seen it spelled two
different ways and
he's a hey i'm telling the [ __ ] heinz
story and he's
he's over there and he tries this ketz
up
and it's made it's a spicy paste
but it's made with fish
ketchup was originally made with [ __ ]
fish who
checky i'm blown away by it too
and so he enjoyed it but he was like
what if we made it out of tomatoes
instead of fish
and that's where [ __ ] ketchup came
from like this dude
built a billion dollar fortune on
[ __ ] like because he was a gardener
his mom made all the kids spend time
with her in the garden for like six
seven hours a day
planting and [ __ ] pulling [ __ ] and he
was the only one in the family that
actually like kept hanging out in the
garden even after like when mom was like
we're done he was still doing it [ __ ]
so he built his empire literally growing
vegetables
and then [ __ ] putting them in a cart
and driving around and [ __ ] selling
them like a like a like a [ __ ]
farmer's market this guy
then he starts like oh maybe we can put
[ __ ] in a bottle
and the bottles are clear so you could
see inside because
other people would make other things and
put them in
different like solid colored jars so you
couldn't see
how [ __ ] up and not pure they were
this guy was all about
purity even before upton sinclair
wrote the book and [ __ ] like that so
before he went after like the
industrialized
factory this was at a time when
obviously it was [ __ ] fascinating i'm
still
talking about this was at a time when
the country
didn't like trust food that they didn't
make either
so like the notion of what like
[ __ ] eat beans that i didn't make
myself what are you crazy they were made
in a factory
thousands of miles away and the heinz
company is responsible
for like the way we eat people going
like oh i guess i can eat something that
somebody else made
very far away and [ __ ] like that it was
[ __ ] fascinating i'd watch a whole
[ __ ] series about this
heinz family and [ __ ] like that all from
like a dude just going like
let's try this they said at one point he
had a notebook like colonel sanders with
like all
well you know [ __ ] formulas and [ __ ]
and he would do
anything he would take any vegetable and
or fruit and stick a something in it
so he had like stuffed mangoes and [ __ ]
at the turn of the century
like now you'd be like that makes sense
anyway enough
sucking heinz dick um different
varieties in that dick
yeah very tasty it's like fish base
um all right back to you so yes hubers
what was it called cubers feed
feedcubers excellent [ __ ]
worth a watch absolutely um number three
is the old guard which we also talked
about in the show we had greka gregorica
on to
talk with uh with uh charlotte
yes wow that got that high on your list
that got that high on my list because i
there's a version of that movie
that is very rote and very kind of like
oh i know what it is it's about you know
immortal assassins doing cool [ __ ]
but there's a level of melancholy to
this movie a level of
of kind of groundedness a lot of it is
brought by charlize theron who plays it
very
close to the best a lot of it is by gina
prince blythewood who directed it who
like brought this sense
of just empathy to it um
and the action is also pretty [ __ ]
stellar but i but i was just in love
with this movie
and in love with what this movie kind of
represented
which was you know the highlander reboot
that i didn't know that i wanted
but i finally got and uh and was just
thrilled by
i enjoyed it i i don't know that it
would have made my top ten that's
interesting let alone my top five
that's high honors um number
two yes number two the last of us part
two
um the video game from the playstation
um
for the ps4 you've talked about this on
the show and
and then you got people attacked you
[ __ ] i got people attacking me for
liking this game
um and so i will happily engender such
attacks
that is a it's a cool graphic right
there who is she hiding from
mark she is hiding if i remember
correctly
she's hiding from there's a there's a
religious
kind of lifestyle stack who lives on
this island it's all kind of set on on
southern california
ish um there's a lot of travel across
the country
but these people who live on an island
who have basically returned to like sort
of monastic ways where they're very much
in harmony with nature
but have no patience for outsiders and
so
um she's being hunted by this particular
cult who you know needs fire and smoke
and arrows and all kinds of awful [ __ ]
to kill people but
the thing that this game does that i
haven't seen in a game before
is it makes you culpable for your
actions it makes you a participant
in a certain level of atrocity that
uh that i've never seen a game do and so
by the time
you get to the end of it you feel as
empty and as wounded
as your main characters do
[ __ ] fun man oh my god
this was like the blues version of
feeling good where it's like
oh no this is going to make me feel so
much worse um and maybe because i don't
feel as bad as the game make me feel
that somehow makes me feel better it's
like probably can you blink oh we
blinked the [ __ ] out of this bleak
um but yeah no i loved it to death
um i haven't played it again but i'm
thinking about it
um because i just have to prepare myself
question
if you play it again will it be
different it'll be different
in that um they call it um i think it's
like the game
new game plus no because part of the
game is all about
including weapons and skills and and all
of that stuff so by the time you get to
the end of the game you're a [ __ ]
superhero
when you play it again you have all of
that [ __ ]
so you you are no longer you know as
challenged to a certain degree
by the frustrating parts of the game and
then you can kind of
take in the new part but it's a bit like
walking to twilight zone again
where you're not going to pay attention
to all of these things that have just
been in the background on your first
playthrough
you're like oh that was there and they
set up that character all the way back
here and
a character you saw over here with that
character over here and
it becomes you know it rewards to
multiple viewing
in the way that i'm going to assume
pennant does but uh
but i don't know if i'll ever watch
pendant again maybe i will i don't know
i can like break a leg or something and
run out of [ __ ] there you know what's
gonna happen a few years will go by
and you'll completely forget and you'll
be like i should give that another spin
yeah and then you'll be like nope
tricked again
[Laughter]
fool me once and then the
number one on my list which we've
already talked about today and which is
the diametric opposite
to last of us part two but lasso
i i have not felt as good as i did
watching ted last night to the point
where i watched it again i've now seen
this entire season
did you i i honestly i felt like
when we finished it i was like oh this
is a good
go to bed series because you can watch
it
laugh and fall asleep while while
watching it because you know the story
already instead
i was thinking about making it a go-to
or doing another spin
because it is really funny really quick
warm relationships and maybe it's like
the older i get this is all i care about
but
i just like the world people hate each
other so [ __ ] much this country's so
divided the world is
[ __ ] divided i just want to see
people who like each other
like and if they don't like each other i
want to see them
slowly come to like each other like that
that's rewarding for me like you know
the last of us sounds very depressing
ted lasso sounds like and is you know
it's
it's the way life could and should be
some funny [ __ ] happens and everybody
kind of tries to get along and grow and
and learn and stuff like that i i
absolutely loved it i could
i co-sign it being way up there on the
list that's for damn sure
yeah i mean it's it reminds me that the
same feeling that i got
especially in the middle of shit's creek
which is
to your point this is just the way the
world could be this is just how we could
treat each other
you know like we don't have to have
excuses or reasons why
people are the way they are we can just
show them learn and grow
and get in touch with the partner
themselves that they've kind of kept at
bay
for a little too long um and build those
bonds of fellowship
that will help you sustain the the bad
times and enjoy the good times
so dead lasso eight man just corrected
me says
nah homie america is divided all good
here in the eu
i mean isn't brexit happening right now
yeah
so and also
kobe so yeah yeah i mean that is yes yes
nothing is all good anywhere no i guess
and
to be fair i guess it never was but
still um
there is a little bit of consternation
in the chat not a lot
but i'm like what that's your number one
but if you haven't seen it
you don't know somebody describes it let
me find it uh
it was perfectly put um
it said it was a warm hug of a show [ __ ]
where is it i mean i think that was more
or less the line yeah but um
where's wait a second where didn't you
were you the one that told me to watch
queen's gambit
um i did tell you to watch queen's
gambit um and i like queen's gambit
but i i at the end of the day the the
beginning of queen's gambit for me was
stronger than the enemy of queens again
i still appreciate it and like this
didn't make your top 10. it just didn't
make the cut i mean it probably should
have been listed on
on the bubble because i do like it quite
a bit
um what almost also made in the list was
that uh that shock of ben wearing a
boston t-shirt
juggling a bunch of dunkin donuts did
you see that
oh it's great it's the most awesome
thing ever like literally he's got one
of those [ __ ] trays
of like iced coffee and coffee and a
bunch of munchkins and he's wearing like
a boston strong t-shirt on and it's just
him going
is he in boston i don't think so i think
he's just [ __ ] here in l.a
but it's it's the perfect counterpoint
to casey's snl bit
that [ __ ] that sketch is one of my
favorite hatchets
in the world it did how they all call it
dunkies and [ __ ] all the black balls are
always like donkeys
i grew up in new jersey we had dunkin
donuts my whole life never heard
one person call it [ __ ] donkeys
that's a very much a massachusetts thing
if i remember correctly it's a
massachusetts company right
i think so yeah but that he's smoking
outside he's like i'm not
i'm not in the i'm not in the place he's
got his figures
he's like i'm not smoking in here i'm
not smoking in here it [ __ ]
that that's not only is that like oh
yeah there it is so there it is
he found it put it back up for the big
man
you take the boy out of boston you can't
take the boston out of the boy man look
at him with his dunkin donuts
um some people i don't drink coffee at
all so i got no allegiance or loyalty
but
east coasters some of them [ __ ] swear
by that the dunkin donuts coffee
i remember when they first came out in
l.a there was a line
for hours to go to santa monica to
take advantage of dunkin donuts and we
went
because we were recent transplants and
my wife was feeling homesick
she's like i want some dunkin donuts
iced tea i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] iced tea
it's like nah
not unless it's in the dmd cup i see
this they have a specific flavor
well just yeah she just it's less about
it's more about being like i miss little
piece of home
nobody's at home where'd she go do you
remember i'm this is deep diving but she
go to middletown north or south
uh i think she went to south there's
dunkin donuts nearby
yeah i mean there always is
and now she's gonna listen i went to the
north you idiot you've known me for what
25 years you know what high school i
went to
no throw rock in jersey you'll hit a
dunkin [ __ ] donuts
um there was uh a list ladies and
gentlemen
uh and mark provided it for you give it
up for mark bernard he told you the 12
his 12 favorite things he looked at on a
screen notice he didn't include
pornography in that list and i guarantee
he looked at some of that on screen but
whatever yeah
no we don't have enough numbers for that
[Laughter]
um all right jc
step up the birthday boy
himself are people uh
dropping dimes in the birthday fun
captain they are people are very
generous for my 40th birthday have they
been that is so awesome it's been
really any specifics that you want to
shout out
larger than others not to um
light on other you know at the at the
expense of others but for those that did
put in a big tip
why not one of the ones i saw was uh
shannon white
jamie cattier's husband put in 138
dollars
which i like because it's like 1138 star
wars
well done so that one stuck out um
a lot of people coming in with uh 20 25
a lot of people who uh i've seen in chat
for the last 10 months which has been
cool because like
this has been without scum and villainy
to hang out at
like this has been my geeky outlet with
uh all these people they've been like
they're like my new regulars it's true
this is the closest going back to bar
life i guess that you've had
uh mark nicholson threw in 100 bucks
nicole lucarelli threw in 50 bucks jay
boogie 1966 through 100 bucks
50 you people are kind man
the good looking out witchy blurred
who's uh
always in that booth with um with jamie
is uh throwing 50 bucks jp
if you're just jumping in now kids uh
it's
jc's birthday he turned 40
for heaven's sake so jc was intending
for his 40th birthday to do the
star wars location tour uh around the
world but he don't get to do that
because nobody gets to go nowhere
anymore and [ __ ]
so uh we put up a link for uh the
birthday pot man everybody put in a
couple bucks and whatnot
uh if you appreciate this show it means
means you appreciate jc and stuff
uh and it's his birthday so we're trying
to raise a little
man links right down below feel free to
click on it uh
jc what questions we got um
where bo h says where can we donate i
just dropped the link in chat
beautiful scotty arms in chat said wawa
over
duncan well [ __ ] yeah uh for some things
not for like donuts like [ __ ]
duncan's got him for donuts and [ __ ] but
wawa for pretzels which duncan doesn't
have i still [ __ ] think about wawa
pretzels and [ __ ]
and then i was traveling cross country
for the reboot roadshow tour last year
and they got you know wawa is pretty
much east coast and very much a
pennsylvania company but i saw some
wawa's on the road where i'm like oh
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] expanding
and they look exactly like the wawa's
and i went in looking for the pretzels
and they're like
you don't do that here they don't do
that that's a pennsylvania [ __ ] thing
man that was a bummer but yeah
i want for president
all right jc what we got okay i was in
new york you didn't have a what say
again
we didn't have wawa's in new york so i
was a 7-eleven kid
i was cumberland farms we didn't get a
wawa until like later
in life um and we didn't have a 7-eleven
and highlands there were 7-elevens but
not
near us man they're up 36 for that
um that's right you're a new york kid
you're a city kid yeah baby
so wait [ __ ] well you didn't even
need convenience stores you probably
didn't have bodegas back then
um when i was a kid in the bronx we had
bodegas and we moved out when i was like
12
to long island which then that's where
you get your friendlies
and your convenience stores and your
dairy farms and that kind of [ __ ]
um but i do have a love for a bodega
because you got to buy that 12 year old
[ __ ] saran wrap that's on there at 2
o'clock in the morning for reasons
um we'll take a life there's your next
t-shirt how goes the t-shirt plug the
t-shirt
yeah the t-shirt sales are going really
well the uh the good folks at embattled
clothing
e-m-b-a-t-t led clothing.com
um i have put out a second t-shirt with
my little
feel of approval on it be humble but let
[ __ ] know
um so yeah go go to that website and if
you use the code mark 15 let's say 15
off your first order but uh i've seen
i've seen lots of pictures on the on the
socials
of people happily brandishing their be
humble gear
that's why i brought it up because i did
see a few tweets of people wearing the
[ __ ] shirt and whatnot i was like i
know that guy
i know that clothier
we just lost pierre cardin which is sad
but mark bernard is ready to step up and
take over
i can slide into the kind of french name
guy exactly what does bernardin mean in
french
um it is actually from what i can tell
an italian name
um bernardini um was an italian name of
probably a
great man or a whatever who made his way
from italy to france
and then if i had to guess you know
slavery happens
and so then the french sort of merchant
or whatever goes
to haiti then san domang and sets up
shop and buy some slaves and
renames them with his last name which is
bernardin and that's where my father is
from my father's side of the family is
all from haiti
okay so i think that's the that's the
entomology and the route of the name
to my driver's license i think a few to
my driver's license
like a few years ago i sent you a
picture of a place a restaurant called
bernardin
yes i'm not there i'm not going i was
like
i know that guy uh they didn't know me i
went to that restaurant i'm like
i'm here where's my puppy did you go to
the restaurant
i did did you pull up a credit card and
be like i thought it would be a whole
[ __ ] thing right like he's here
he's here
no leopold oh
i just put me i'm watching channel 5 and
seeing that
[ __ ] bugs bunny repeat for the
zillionth time um
yes where's the shirt again tell them
where to get the shirt
embattledclothing.com or if you go to my
twitter or
my instagram they're both in the in the
sort of about me the profile
sections or links to that uh that
storefront
uh for me if you wanna uh financially
send things my way you can
join that kevin smith club ladies and
gentlemen that kevinsmithclub.com i just
spent
the holiday digging up a bunch of new
videos that we're gonna put in the
smithsonian screening room
which is becoming an archive of like
everything i know thank you i was very
happy with that
um i uh but uh there's some cool old
[ __ ] in there and whatnot and i found a
this amazing i think i've talked about
it before
like after we did zach and miri and they
were putting the dvd together
like seth sat for this interview seth
rogen and did this amazing [ __ ] story
about uh the guy who
is well i don't want to trigger anybody
but it's a
it's a name that's uh the associated
with
like uh everything wrong
uh so just wait for it here we go
trigger warning
harvey weinstein so this is before
anybody knew
all that stuff um seth tells this
story of interacting with him and it is
he does it with evan goldberg but evan's
not on camera
seth is on camera portraying himself
on a phone call and evan is off camera
portraying
harvey weinstein and it's really like
really really funny
so i'm gonna throw that up there and
stuff like that i found a bunch of cool
stuff so
if you're into that if you're into plus
one the podcast i do with my wife and
education and stuff like that that
kevinsmithclub.com
um all right jc give us a i've seen that
seth rogen video like 10 years ago when
we started working together and it is
it's worth it it's so phenomenal and i i
just
hear this is i mean we could talk about
here
like do you it has literally nothing to
do
with anything that we now
think of when we think of harvey
weinstein no and it doesn't paint him in
a good light either
it no it just it really doesn't like
seth shits on him and seth and evan
really [ __ ] on him hardcore but
i vazilate on sharing it by virtue of
the fact that
i don't want people being like this
isn't [ __ ] funny harvey weinstein was
a monster and
which you know i [ __ ] agree with but
at the same time this isn't a
this this makes him this doesn't make
him look more monstrous but it does make
him look
you know bad it's not like it paints
them in a good light um
and it's legit funny i just don't know
if like
you know how how many years was it
before people could joke about
the vietnam war how many years was it
before people could joke about
things that are harrowing and stuff like
that and even though there's nothing in
this
that jokes about that that just hearing
people talk about the guy could trigger
people so i get
i get like you know kind of i don't know
maybe i shouldn't put it up but it's
funny and and in innocent in its weird
way and stuff as
but it's also just lethal because they
[ __ ] roast the guy
straight to hell and stuff but what are
your do you in your memory of it
is that okay to share you think i i
think so i don't
it it doesn't delve into his
horribleness
but it does not paint him in a good way
in any way shape or form uh and it's
definitely
uh seth is pretty brutal towards him
uh alex alex ray palpa papa palpatine in
chat goes we could joke about vietnam
now
maybe i guess like well i mean you know
i don't mean like we all sit around and
[ __ ] like mock it and [ __ ] but
they've
they've done you know comedies about it
and [ __ ] haven't they migrated
thunder was that set in the vietnam war
no they were making a vietnam movie
right
but yeah um all right jc give us some
questions
okay oh a couple anthony gonzalez just
said in chat the big sick had a 911 joke
it worked
yeah i mean but it's just some people
like
you just i like i like i i just want to
make people feel good in this life i
don't want to [ __ ] like trigger
anybody and [ __ ] but
i think if you if you're if you put a
trigger warning
up with it so people who are very
sensitive don't watch it
but if you don't like that guy
and you watch it you will
be happy to see them talking about that
guy in that way
yeah you'll feel that you'll feel very
validated yeah
this ain't this is you know i'm not like
it's kicking a guy while he's down but
it's just
like to be fair seth
like smelled [ __ ] he didn't smell
the [ __ ] real [ __ ] the horrible [ __ ]
that harvey did
but he like instantly was kind of like
this guy something wrong with this guys
and that's kind of reflected in the
in the video um all right here we go
okay uh just so it's on the record
i was i looked it up i had 145 hours of
fasting
so that's your there's your your goal
good luck buddy
[ __ ] all right so if i look at my thing
right now i mean this is not
[ __ ] on topic but still um any more
hours right
if i'm looking i was i'm at 117. i'm
about to be at 118 hours so
how many more hours to get to 145. 27.
oh man it's like another whole [ __ ]
day
longer than the whole [ __ ] day yeah
it's about two sleeps
um all right all right um we also have
some
yeah i'm within [ __ ] shooting discs
to fire what are they called [ __ ]
striking distance
bruce willis film um i've got to be able
to [ __ ] go there i mean right now the
app tells me i'm in deep ketosis man
they're like oh [ __ ] you're all about
the autophagy and whatnot
uh it's a pretty sweet app but i use it
for this
part just because it keeps the you know
[ __ ] it tells you how long you've
been doing it and [ __ ]
um but all right so that means god damn
it that means another
[ __ ] whole day to catch jc's record
um
i also when i came off of it i did it
was the day before thanksgiving in 2019
so i came off and then i ate and eight
and eight well honestly they
say like a lot of videos i've watched
and a lot of things i've read online
from like doctors and physicians and
people that practice
fasting was like after the fast you know
naturally you gotta ease into it and
whatnot because your body hasn't
consumed solids in like a certain amount
of time
but um you know as the as you pull out
of the fast by day two
by day three naturally the body craves
i don't know what you crave but the body
tends to crave oils and fats because
we've given up a lot of that and stuff
um
and they've in the reports i've read you
can do
you can you can eat a bunch and it's not
like you're instantly gonna
gain it all because your body is now
functioning
yeah you can do stuff with it and stuff
anyway enough about that
um we had one guy in the chat shout out
that the aew
wrestler brodie lee passed away that was
his wrestling name
taken from brody and jason lee
yeah he's a friend of uh chris jericho's
i hit up
you know i'm friends with chris jericho
and i texted him when i saw he passed
away
and i was like were you guys close and
he said i brought him into aw i've known
him for years you're such a lovely guy
he was just at my house
and yeah he was a big fan of ball rats
so he pulled his name brodie lee from
brody and the character and jason lee
and he passed away from um not from
covet but from
some lung related thing very young too
right he was only like
41 or something like that
yeah i don't have the i don't have his
age but i know he was very young and i
saw a lot of
uh nerd love for him on the internet
yeah it is
me too and my twitter feed all week and
stuff um well
our hearts go out to his family and his
fans and people he left behind
um also quite a man says
wait what was the starvation app it's
not a starvation app
it's called zero it's basically just
it's it's a timer it's not not a
starvation app
um [ __ ] right there like i want the
non-smoking app
oh that's easy murray nathan said stole
if timothy leary made a pixar movie
uh just to run just to rub it in
devildog 2600 hz
said i had two bowls of beef stew while
watching
rated rated mik said i once went a whole
month without
eating i mean that's possible there are
people that actually go to programs
where they
spend a month not eating as long as
you're drinking water it's not like
you're not consuming anything but if you
have a body mass
index that indicates that your body can
live
off of itself for a long time i guess
that's possible
but i would have to be like really
preoccupied
because it's not the hunger that gets
you it's the [ __ ] boredom man that's
what i learn every time i do a fast i'm
like i don't really eat when i'm hungry
i eat to pass time i eat as
entertainment that's something that i
really like to
break with and stuff and and i've been
able to and then
fell into a mindset of like eating
[ __ ] food and watching
movies is wonderful and it is but like
so is
you know [ __ ] i guess doing heroin
because
a lot of people do it and it's bad you
know so is at one point smoking
cigarettes used to rock and then one day
you know you're
like this is bad for you so all the good
[ __ ] i mean
all things in moderation i guess
somebody smart once said something like
that yes and everything that tastes good
is bad for you
oh it's why god damn it just makes not
stuff fair
um all right man okay uh
starsaber 666. if you guys
and uh we had a lot of cobra kai
questions but since
mark hasn't seen it this is the uh
kind of the i would say the compromise
here
if if you had to start a karate dojo
what would you call it
and who would be your sensei and
champion
from any pop culture right so
like you know you could call it uh
the rat dojo and pic master splinter
you know and have um
you know uh the guy from i don't know as
your champion
so there's there's the first question i
like so i gotta pick uh
a character who knows a lot about
martial arts
and name i get to name the dojo and then
i
get to pick the sensei
okay um
well let me see tempted to go shang chi
because
you know master of kung fu is is coming
up
um hmm
well i'm gonna go deep cuts well maybe
not be deep cuts but
it's not the most obvious character in
dc comics they've got
uh you know what [ __ ] that i mean i was
gonna pick lady shiva
[ __ ] batman it's the dojo of the bat
dojo
and bruce wayne is my [ __ ] sensei i
can't believe i had to think about that
it was a long road to get there it
really was man i had to take the [ __ ]
lady shiva parkway to get to [ __ ]
batman
but yes bruce wayne uh he's the [ __ ] he
can [ __ ]
disarm somebody 160 different ways from
his standing position he could [ __ ]
take a life if he wanted to by 480
different ways
like come on [ __ ] that's yeah him for
sure
yeah that's your sense saying it's the
bat dojo yeah
okay um my seventh day
is neo from the matrix um
the dojo is called the last dragon
neo that's a good poll why didn't you go
with morpheus though he taught neo
yeah but neo is better than morpheus
um you know what it's a hot take and
you're saying it 26 years after the
movie
but i'm glad you said it
was better than more views
particularly in the second one let's be
honest but first one
morpheus is is it on a stick man hello
zion are we ready to party
um and then my main character is bruce
leroy group leroy is learning
from neo who's bruce lee roy
from the last dragon holy [ __ ]
yes my god [ __ ] let me see the rhythm
of the night
into the morning get a little debarge
going
oh wow that is a deep cuts and good pull
no no who's the master sure no
no um that was a good question that led
us to some decent answers although my
answer was pretty basic but
[ __ ] you asked me for a fighter
[ __ ]
batman what a great dojo too because
you're in the cave
that's cool you had to take the shiva
jug handle to get
to the bruce wayne expressway i did
there's the the shiva turn off
exit 117 got me to bruce i got off at
exit it's 117 and then i had to go back
on the turnpike to get up to gotham city
yes
i'll uh i'll finish i'll round mine off
where my master would be splinter and my
champion would be hong kong oh
good poll matthew cox said mojo jojo
mojo jojo presents mojo jojo's dojo of
mojo
fantastic fantasy yes
i used to watch that show all the time
with my kid
i haven't seen the new incarnation
anybody
i mean i don't even know where to find
it
that's the thing man we live in a world
now where like like there's a [ __ ]
like i didn't know where uh which would
call it um
one night in miami was there's another
movie too
oh the uh the movie with
uh carrie mulligan in it um
oh not perfect something about
you know like what was woman you know
forget the title
but i want to say ordinary decent
criminal but that's not it it's
yeah but it's where she [ __ ] like
you know takes revenge against mustard
dudes and stuff
um but i didn't know where that was
either i can't but i don't think it's
out yet
yeah you'd think there would be app
promising young woman promising young
woman
there it is there it is um
okay next question number two
okay uh let's do this one it's kind of
wacky
they see somebody that they can't find a
place to donate
uh let me drop i can drive okay ladies
and gentlemen if you want to wish him a
happy birthday or if you like this show
show him that you love him and the show
uh by
dropping a few duckets in his buckets
for his
birthday 40 years old he survived 40.
[ __ ]
years i do not believe it
you know i don't uh i don't really sweat
birthdays i haven't really celebrated
birthdays
again typically i'm like well if i say
i'm gonna show up at scum and villainy
we'll get a lot of people to show up at
the bar on a tuesday night
um but this one 40 hits kind of hard
it hits pretty hard you're at the unless
you've got
amazing [ __ ] genes that take you deep
you're in the mid
you're you're middle age my friend open
the middle yeah it's weird
i uh i keep going to the um
the bilbo baggins quote from lord of the
rings which is
uh i'm old gandalf i don't look old but
i feel it in my bones
i feel it in my heart because
everybody's like you look
25 and i was like i do and i still have
acne
but uh
i will be honest with you i'm [ __ ]
shocked and appalled to hear a star
died in the world star wars kid like
yourself pull a [ __ ]
lord of the rings hobbit max quote
express how you feel about age when i'm
sure han solo said something in the
recent trilogy that would have been more
appropriate
um you're just gonna mind alec guinness
trying to get out
of that storage compartment in the
falcon and like just
stopping because
okay question two this one's a little
wacky but i kind of like it
um if you guys had the authority to put
bazlerman
in charge to direct a dc or marvel
character in a spin-off movie who would
it be
and what story would baz tell
wow i got it you go
dazzler
um and he could do let me see so he did
uh
what was the the thing
so let's take an old story dazzler in a
star is born
type of story oh that's nice thank you
in his hands in the hands of uh what's
his name again
mormon that would be wonderful and stuff
i think i'm gonna go um sadly not as
disco fantastic as that
um i'm gonna go to flying graces
i think a baslerman circus movie um
gives you all of that kind of
theatricality and
you know pomp and circumstance and
heightened emotions and
literally people sawing through the air
until it's a tragedy by the end
um uh the tragedy of which a young boy
rises
to decide to you know ride shotgun with
an old man
with a predilection for putting children
in harm's way
why i mean not for nothing but why
haven't they done that as a standalone
movie at this point just the robin story
yeah like because the end of the movie
like you just
you know you end with the tragedy but
then like uh [ __ ] he gets adopted
by this [ __ ] billionaire and [ __ ] and
you don't have to go into the batman and
robin of it all but like
that's that's a pretty compelling story
i mean i know they did it in batman
forever but you can get away with a
whole
dick grayson robin movie i mean it's
it's [ __ ]
annie but with a [ __ ] boy
it's like i'm in the circus and i'm
having a great time my parents died and
suddenly here's daddy warbucks
who rolls up in this crazy [ __ ] car
he says you want to come live with me
kid
the gun will come out tomorrow
and shoot bruce's parents and mine
tomorrow
they'll be guns
uh what a great poll annie it is [ __ ]
annie man
but also it's like you need kids to be
into this [ __ ] and they are into this
but like put a kid up there
like marvel's smart they're doing ms
marvel and she's a [ __ ] kid
so kids are gonna be able to watch a
kid's show if i was dc man i
i would legit do a 11
10 11 year old [ __ ] robin story with
the flying graysons you're right you got
the [ __ ] circus
you know you can weave in it's coming to
gotham so you don't go to gotham right
away
often is your maybe second midway
through the second act and your third
act or your second and third act
get to see the dynamics of the family
and stuff you know and it's mostly
you're focused on
the kid like it's i'm not saying it's
home alone but you get yourself like
a mcauley culkin kind of kid who's
interested and dick running around and
doing [ __ ] that like
you know kind of foreshadows what he
will
eventually wind up doing and like if i
was a kid and i was watching a kid movie
about like this is
robin before he's robin i guess the only
question is like if i was a kid
and you were like this is the robin
movie and he never dressed up as robin
i might be [ __ ] mad so maybe we got
to get him his robin somewhere like the
end shot
for sure he's [ __ ] you know wearing
the outfit yeah yeah i mean but
i also think that it's it gets to be a
movie about a kid who learns some [ __ ]
about his parents
right like that's the story it's the
when you go from being a child to a
grown up is when you
discover that your parents are just
human and they're just [ __ ] people
and they make mistakes
and like his parents got into dutch with
the [ __ ] mob
and like they put out a hit on him and
they die in front of his eyes
but like that idea of you know the idol
of childhood wonder
is pulled away from you slowly and then
very very quickly
can't you just see like the really
beautiful scene where he meets
like bruce wayne for the first time and
like they're
sitting in a room and he's trying to
communicate to this kid whose whole
world is [ __ ] falling apart and stuff
and you know here's this guy who doesn't
have the problems that him or his
family had and stuff clearly would never
be you know
wrapped up with criminal elements or
anything like that you know this old
multi-billionaire fellow and they relate
over you know with you know there comes
that moment and you get the lump in your
throat where there's a long silence and
then bruce finally says
my parents died too you know and [ __ ]
like you start building trust between
those two characters i'm getting [ __ ]
hairs on my
on my arm think about it we didn't
really get that that much in in the
movies
like we got chris o'donnell who was like
38
when he was bombing so and you know and
[ __ ] whole time him and
george clooney bickered and [ __ ] so it
feels like
you could do a really wonderful like
kids movie about
dick crazy i want to see your i want to
pay to see your dick grayson movie my
friend
yeah well it'll be on hbo max because
it's a smaller riskier film
it is it is and you can cast like you
don't you could cast
diverse as [ __ ] and whatnot you know
it's baz lorman at this point
right you're [ __ ] going crazy you can
do whatever you want
like yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah into the robin
verse
into the rotten verse it's a shame that
you can't get tom holland
um to once again play like you know 15
years old even though he's like 27.
but like that you want that kind of kid
who still feels like a kid still feels
young
but you can work harder because he's an
adult
through the [ __ ] kids hours on a set
sometimes i love this show sometimes i
hate it because like i get real
psyched about a thing that don't exist
like i can't wait to watch this [ __ ]
robin show and i'm like oh yeah
it's just in our imaginations it don't
exist yet
someday it will because you know what we
talk about [ __ ] on this show and then
weirdly it winds up happening later on
somebody's [ __ ] listening paid for it
though
no we never get the money but we're part
of a long tradition when it comes to
that
it's an oral condition truly um
all right jt what's our third question
and once we've once again before we dive
into the third
it is jc's birthday ladies and gentlemen
give him a birthday tip
he can't give him a birthday [ __ ]
because he's married and he has a dwell
he's not oh he's practically married
he's a
family man with a child but you can give
him birthday money for heaven's sakes
so there's a link somewhere click on
that link
drop my man a few uh a few bucks a few
uh
drachma a few uh rubles
shekels uh euros they still have those
right
um pound sterling uh
just give them your best man anything uh
or just
send them a message right here in chat
all right jc take us home with our third
question
all right uh that last question was from
bo h which i forgot to announce
well done bull h let's see hold on hold
on
hold on chris colen and chat just
[ __ ] nailed it bro
finn wolfhard is robbing
that's pretty good you know what i'm
saying and it don't have to be like oh
he's
[ __ ] robbing rob rob pattinson's
robin
stand-alone [ __ ] robin story yep
um i want this so [ __ ]
bad god damn it sometimes i hate the
chat cause everyone's so smart
you know it's crazy like when i first
started my career i thought i was like
the smartest person in the world
like where i was like i'm making star
wars jokes that nobody's ever made
now everybody the internet let me find
out that there's a
there's billions of me out there i'm not
unique i'm no [ __ ] snowflake and [ __ ]
like we all have the same [ __ ] ideas
so there's a bunch of people out there
right now who are like yeah
[ __ ] robin movie and [ __ ]
uh all right jc birthday this last
question is not from fat black patrick
[Laughter]
swayze
uh let's see okay
last one uh ryan lestad asks
what's the content you're looking
forward to most
in 2021
what is the what what content are you
looking forward to most
in 2021 so like snyder cuts
or i am looking forward to the
marvel shows on disney plus like i i am
so
i'm a little scared how much i'm a
little scared that i'm a grown ass man
i'm not scared but i'm a little
there's concern for how much i want to
watch one division because that type of
enthusiasm
you know could not possibly be rewarded
like i could want to see this thing so
bad and when they show it to me i'm like
that's [ __ ] wanda vision the one in
my head was better
that doesn't ever seem to be the case
with marvel's stuff
um so i'm not that worried but that's
just a long way of saying like i i can't
wait to watch that
that one more than anything else like
that i keep watching the ads over and
over and it
it hits me here if it's the story i
think it is
well she's just gone [ __ ] crazy and
she's building her own world
and everyone on the outside is trying to
[ __ ] get her out like the new trailer
do you see the new spot they dropped
where like somebody's going like wanda
can you hear us are you okay
are you trapped like she it looks like
she's building this [ __ ] world and
[ __ ] which would indicate
when you get to multi you know the
doctor strange and the multiverse
madness
that she's essentially the big bad so i
[ __ ]
cannot wait this show seems funny but it
also seems like it's going to be [ __ ]
very serio
comic it's going to be tragic as well
there's going to be
some [ __ ] [ __ ] going on and you got
two amazing [ __ ] actors
like i'll watch [ __ ] those two cats
play these characters all day long and i
think the spots are wonderful
um and really sweet and stuff but i
think there's an underlying
sadness to this show that i can't
[ __ ] wait to get you got to think
about it think about her at the end of
end game
when she was just like [ __ ] i mean
she almost [ __ ] killed thanos because
she loved
vision so much and [ __ ] so she was all
like in a real dark space
and this show that they keep showing us
ads for she's bright
and happy and doing sit-commie voices
and things
as clearly a mask for all the pain and
[ __ ] like
vision can't be alive she's brought him
back or some such
i don't know i can't wait to watch the
show but it's because of that like i
you know some people are way into the
falcon in the winter soldier of course
i'm gonna watch that
uh some people are into uh what's the
other one oh loki
of course i'll watch that but this wanda
vision show i'm telling you based on the
ads i keep watching
i'm like this seems special to me like
i'm [ __ ]
in it seems like it was made for for me
like like it has all the elements that
i'm [ __ ] looking for and stuff
and i don't think it's gonna end happy
and that's you know that
it feels like it has an empire strikes
back ending coming to it
and i'm [ __ ] so here for that so i
know there's a bunch of [ __ ] coming out
and look i'm very excited for my own
thing and mark's thing as well
we've got masters of the universe coming
out on netflix this year
they haven't announced when but it is
coming out this year and i've seen it
and it's [ __ ]
fantastic it is wonderful and i'm not
taking credit for i'm not saying i'm a
genius
powerhouse animation knocking out the
part that cast we got
knocking it out the park and the story
we're telling is like adventurous is
really joyful
that all being said i i think i'm still
[ __ ] looking forward to wanda vision
the most you know and the batman movie
but i honestly wanna vision more like
i've seen many batman movies and i look
forward to matt reeves batman and i look
forward to rob pattinson the trailers
[ __ ] amazing one of the best trailers
of the last year
but wanda vision seems like something
different so i'm i'm
that's the one i'm [ __ ] i'm here for
we only gotta wait like [ __ ] 13 more
days
yes nice what about you i
uh i similarly am excited for one
division a little mobile stuff
i similarly cannot wait to see mo too i
haven't seen any of it yet
um so i'm excited for that but i think i
think it's goon
man i think i can't wait to [ __ ] see
doom
um dune dune i'm a dude i'm a dune dude
and you know i'm an evil new fan i'm
i in this story to see it realize that
this scale
feels like the kind of thing you don't
get as a as a nerd anymore
because dune while yes an international
bestseller
is not on anybody's top of their list of
the hey
here's a piece of ip we just spent 100
million dollars making
and the fact that they did makes me so
happy and the fact that hopefully i'll
get to see it on a movie screen
um similarly makes me so [ __ ] jazzed
so
yes bring me bring me to arrakis
movie looks as thick as the book that it
is based on
it just it looks like they left nothing
on the floor
um and it looks like true science
fiction
like it's taking place on different
planets and different worlds and whatnot
um we still haven't seen like a
like a [ __ ] ton of it yet but what we've
seen
is spot on for what i know of dune
like i've not seen anything where i'm
like hey [ __ ] dune
like it looks like dune just done way
better way more expensive and stuff and
when i say way better i don't mean to
uh [ __ ] on the david lynch one because i
[ __ ] love the david lynch
dune movie like i absolutely [ __ ]
love it i think it's wonderful and
and you know it it's got a fraught
history in terms of how it got to the
to the screen and whatnot and then since
then there's been multiple versions
where his name's not on it and they put
in
material to try to make people
understand and [ __ ] so i love
[ __ ] the the david lynch dude that
being said
it's kind of like gone like well i loved
batman 66
but this [ __ ] tim burton batman in
1989 this looks like it could be
something that's kind of like what dune
has the feel to it where it's like
you know this story but like you will
not believe how much [ __ ] money we
spent on it
and we hired a genius to make the
[ __ ] thing yeah
so that's that's the one that's the one
for me that uh
then i'll be you know burning the oil of
2020 to get to
it's a good poll very good poll jc what
about you
since you're here and it's your birthday
for heaven's sakes
honestly the your motu series i loved
uh he-man growing up and when they
re-did he-man in 2002 i was like
a fiend for it i actually like
the yeah the 2002 like reboot i bought
all the action figures and i was well
let's do the math
2002 i would have been i mean i was what
22 22 years old yeah so um
so i'm super psyched for that i think uh
one division i'm excited for we're gonna
do uh
like we did for mandalorian scum and
villainy's twitch we'll do a
like a breakdown of that show i've got
some marvel experts
doing that um
i think that's i mean those are the two
things i agree with you guys i think
falcon and winter soldier will be good
but i think one division is just
it's uh it's it's such a
risk it's so weird and wacky and out
there
um but also so s
like perfect to do uh
and it's it's earned as well because
we've spent so much time
with her in the movies but not
front and center you know what i'm
saying like they'll let her
him her and him like come to the surface
but then action and into other things
so this is the first time we get to
actually spend
a bunch of time with wanda like you know
and and find out who she really is
um and and you know what they've set up
through the spots we've seen and all we
know based on the descriptions
is a fascinating story of somebody who's
like
grieving this is a story of [ __ ]
grief at the end of the day
and how you deal with grief and we all
go through that so as
spectacular as the show may seem i think
there's going to be connective material
for everybody because
everybody has [ __ ] lost somebody and
they would do anything in the world to
bring that [ __ ] person back
and imagine if you were that you felt
that way plus you had the ability to
warp reality you were the most powerful
[ __ ] being in the marvel universe
so yeah i think it's gonna be amazing i
can't [ __ ] wait if i'm wrong
and if the show i'm seeing in my head is
not the show that i'm [ __ ] seeing
in the trailers well you'll hear about
it every week while me and mark talk
about it
and deep dive i i'm happy and sad that
they're
dishing them out one a week um but
they've trained me with mandalorians so
i'm okay with that gives me something to
look forward to
but you know [ __ ] this is a show that
i would i would put aside my script to
watch
put aside my script step on your neck
burn your house down
i literally legit thought about at one
point i was like i do have [ __ ] kevin
feige's number man
like is it like untoward to be like bro
just give me three episodes
like can i just watch the thing you
qualified you for it's like listen
can you give me a screener link he's
like oh my god
kevin smith's gonna ask me for a [ __ ]
job and i'm like no i'm not
i'm gonna ask you can i watch the first
three episodes of wannabe
i'm a fan not a filmmaker goddammit um
yeah man there's some good kit to look
forward to
i think i'd also be remiss and have to
turn in my bar card if i didn't say
the book of boba fett is that oh that's
so that's coming at the end
this year um it'll start in december
uh and i'm not a big boba fett fan
personally
but with favreau and filoni behind it
and robert rodriguez
you know even if you're not like a big
fan like you've got those three guys
like they could do you know they could
do anything and you should be excited
and also it's like event if the
mandalorian has proven anything for the
last two seasons
they can take something you're not
necessarily a fan of and make it
something that you're now part of my
[ __ ] religion and
he's like look what they did with
[ __ ] boba fett on this show
like and now they're going to give him
his own [ __ ] show yeah i think that's
going to be fantastic
um all right man oh so on chat
vic 3 said imagine a david lynch war
shark movie
that'd be fantastic man holy [ __ ]
that's good i hadn't thought about that
all about
um yeah i guess that's it
i'm just getting the paypal tip worked
thanks says man
mana 1r1 don't forget folks
jc's birthday is happening right now we
put up a link where you can uh
donate um
franco villavilla said as a homeless
person i often go days without eating my
longest was seven days
um yeah i mean you never want to not eat
because you
like can't eat but i guess there's a
line there
um
uh all right man we're [ __ ]
we're out of material aren't we
can't say anything more because
everything's been said it's a pretty
good
show two hours and 45 minutes tonight
about
he didn't think we would have enough
news i literally was like do we have any
news and
i remember mark texted like you could do
a short show
what we didn't have to be two and a half
hours
two and a half hours and we didn't even
really have major news to talk about man
nope crazy it was all that uh blowing a
cobra kai
and [ __ ] in the list
list went through shorter than i
imagined it would have
you kind of went through it like for 12
movies we
kind of went through them pretty pretty
fast but we did deep dive on lasso
and we did deep dive on seoul so i guess
that was some time right there
yeah did you have fun out there ladies
and gentlemen
if you did uh show your appreciation to
jc
for his birthday give him a tip he just
turned 40 for heaven's sakes
my tip is [ __ ] it's all downhill from
here
10 more years 40s were great man [ __ ]
you know 50 is where it all [ __ ]
falls apart
but happy birthday they see um
uh many many happy [ __ ] returns thank
you for hosting the show
and making this version of the show work
as well as we're all
hidden from one another until [ __ ]
vaccinated um there if you like this
show kids
and uh i do and it seems a bunch you do
we've have
num wonderful numbers lately thank you
so much uh apparently this time
on saturdays of us doing the show seems
to be the sweet spot
um at least online because the
you know it allows not just the east
coast and the west coast of america
but it also allows us to pick up our our
british fans as well
what time is it there when the show
begins
um it's gotta be a year like 11.
apparently it's like not that late man
so thank you for
staying up with us and stuff and so
we'll keep doing it around
this time every week because it feels
like this is a regular slot now
we found a regular slot until we can go
back to a bar yeah and then it'll be at
night not as four o'clock [ __ ] what are
you nuts
um if you like uh what what happened
here today
give it up for the guy without whom it
don't happen mr mark bernard ladies and
gentlemen
thank you sir and that is the birthday
the jc birthday edition of fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen i'm kevin
smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next time
next saturday four o'clock same
bat time we literally have the same bad
time now staying
fat channel rather smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith uh wakanda
forever
indeed may the fourth be with you
you